the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome to our coverage of the
2023 spring chess classic my name is
Julian perlaco and I'm joined by women's
Grandmaster Tata of abrahamian and today
we get to look at some fighting games in
the fighting in the final round of this
tournament welcome everyone to the final
round of the spring test classic we're
going to Crown two Champions today no
matter what if there's a tie break if
there's a two-way tiebreak four-way tie
break six-way time rank at the end of
the day we are going to have a winner
and let's take a look at the standings
and see what we have ahead of us and
entering the day we have a three-way tie
for first place between Benjamin gladura
who won his game and he was playing
Darius spirits and he leapfrogged out
his spirits and joined the lead with
Christopher you and Benjamin Park and we
have a pack of players Sam Sevilla and
Aliens Nick Darius sweets and Yasser
quesada who also won his game yesterday
joining uh half a point behind the
leaders and in group b
we have a soul leader Felix blauberger
who was playing Jason Liang did really
long game yesterday he had a bit of a
scare with the white pieces he was under
pressure but managed to draw the game
and is entering this round a full point
ahead of Jason Liang so all he needs to
do is score today half a point a full
point and he will be guaranteed to take
the section if you're just joining us
the tournament format is uh the players
will be playing in game in 90 uh for the
first sporting moves in afternoon 40
They will receive an extra 30 minutes
for the rest of the game and throughout
the entire game they receive a 30 second
increment so after each move they will
receive an additional 30 seconds
um so today is the final day there will
be no more rounds after
um uh after this this round but there
will be a playoff potentially if um
Christopher you does not win his game
then there will be a playoff where uh
the games will be cited by game a game
in 10 minutes with a 25 second delay and
if uh if that doesn't Crown a winner
then there will be an Armageddon game
where uh White will receive five minutes
and Blackboard will see four minutes
with uh draw odds and let's take a look
at the pairings and see where we are and
we did see the players in the playing
call and in group a we have two key
matchups the two leaders playing each
other the battle of the Benjamins
Benjamin Buck versus Benjamin gladero
and actually this game has already ended
in a draw so these two players are tied
for first place and the only way for us
to have a clear winner is Christopher
you is able to
defeat the yaser quesada Perez with the
black pieces so this will be our two key
matchups of the day so let's take a look
at what has happened we can quickly look
at the game between Park and glidera to
see how that game ended so it ended in a
three-fold repetition
so the buck is playing with the white
pieces and we have a sloth
and we have an exchange love very very
solid
and in this position so because black is
going to play E6 it makes sense to give
up the bishop because all the spawns are
in the light squares
so Bishop goes to D3 Knight before
Bishop is forced to go to B1 of course
white wants to save the bishop and also
cover the square
Bishop D6
from goes to C8
very symmetrical position pound
structure on the king side and now we're
going to see a repetition
and a funny repetition
Bishop H4 threatening to double the
pawns Bishop B7 to on pin and then
Bishop G3 trying to preserve the Bishop
Harry suppose I guess black was actually
I'm not even sure if black was really
threatening very much but
um I think that uh Bach was more than
happy just to try to secure a tie for
first yeah take his chances in the play
the player type
and so so far the type for first place
and there are actually a number of
players who can join them so first we
have to look at this Christopher U game
and unfortunately for Christopher in
this position he is down a piece he does
have a lot of pawns for it but there's
this C Pawn there is running if we took
the C5 Pawn off the board then black
would have some good fighting chances
but with this Pawn on the board and it's
hard to imagine any kind of Perpetual
because I believe I should be able to
run to B2 where I will be safe
for example if check even Queen D4 right
yeah Queen D4 here is actually quite
strong and of course any kind of
exchange this will be a loss because
this Pawn will Queen very quickly
this one is I can move the pieces so
this part already will queen with the
assistance of this bishop so this will
be game over so the trade of Queens just
loses immediately and uh I don't see any
perpetuals once the King goes to B2 and
the queen goes to C3 and once we get
that configuration so let's say
if I don't have Queen before I don't
play Queen D4 once I get my queen on C3
not only do you not have any checks I
also put my queen behind the pond and I
will start pushing this Pawn
and it's very difficult for these three
pawns to move and if you move for
example this F5 Pawn ever moves I think
you might also find that your king might
be in danger if I'm able to put my P
push up on this diagonal so this
position looks like lost for Christopher
we can take a look and see how we got
here
let me call the web back
of course it's a sicilian but he did not
uh he did not
player Oh Queen C7 Bishop B2 yeah there
are many moves in this position if four
is a move it should be three is a move
we should be two G4 is a movie three is
a move
uh I feel like there are some Sicilians
against which you can just play any move
against neither for example and his
Queen D2 Bishop D2 H4 H3 A3 A3 yeah
it's a knight of six uh so castling King
side
is where a white can Castle queenside
but he tries to play more solid and we
did talk to quesada Perez yesterday and
he was saying that he last time he
played Christopher was in the
continental and it was a draw so he was
expecting
um yeah I was looking at lines that were
similar this was a while ago but I was
looking at a line similar to this for
black and I always found that the Knight
on C6 is pretty annoying you would
rather have your knight on D7 I think in
these lines so I think the claim for
white is with this classical setup that
the night's like just a little bit
misplaced on C6 you would rather have A6
Knight D7 as your setup
yeah and and a lot of
um okay in the classical Sicilian the
net goes to C6 but in the night orbs the
Knight goes to D7 to C5 in stravaningan
in a lot of positions it goes to C5
sometimes it goes to D7 A6 B5 and then
goes to C4
A6 and queen E1 and uh
takes takes Queen G3 this is a very
common idea
bringing the move to the queen side and
uh King said and white is starting an
attack The Rook will go only one the
bishop can go either F3 or D3 and then
E5 and uh slowly building an attack so
Bishop B7 is already threatening before
so he prevents it
or goes T1
Bishop D3 and this Bishops look uh
pretty menacing looking at the king
there's nothing here so far
because you don't want to take on F6 if
you go E5 in some positions if these
pawns get traded off
uh if you manage to get it to an end
game then this Pawn is actually becomes
a weakness we did see that game against
the dire swords and other money Mishra
where there was a sicilian end game on
the side black was just cruising Black's
position is so comfortable I mean it
wasn't enough to win the game but the
position was just simply comfortable
but for black to reach that position he
needs to survive and to ruxiate so roxy8
we see the bar immediately changes and
the problem with a move like Rook C8
immediately E5 is very scary because if
you do something like this
I was wondering if I can take
ah Quinn
yeah the Queen the queen trade saves
Black's life there otherwise they think
black would have been in trouble but
once The Rook moves this F5 moves
becomes so much scary and the point I
was trying to make because in some lines
when this Rook moves and you have to
move your knight there's all kinds of
sacrifices associated with it with this
um with this kind of ideas maybe it
doesn't work right here but the Rook
usually wants to stay on f8 and it's not
very happy to be moving from
from my f8 yeah there's a famous way
game I believe against brazon Batista
where he won in this structure after E5
and then he played some Rook F7
sacrifice very famous game
and Rook F3 is played instead Queen H3
now E5 is a very big threat
also Rook G3 so white here is attacking
with the pieces rather with the pawns
and in a lot of Sicilians when we Castle
opposite sides we see pound attacks and
but here
is bringing all the pieces in yeah I
think when you castle look inside In the
Sicilian you don't really want to go G4
because the bishop on B7 lined up with
the Kane will be tactically vulnerable
in the future
so G6 is played because E5 opening this
bishop was already extremely dangerous
so Rook G3
A5 so I think black needs to do
something like this you cannot just live
with this threat of E5 forever
so takes and takes the pawn and Rook C5
really nice really nice Rook lift so if
I move this uh I think this queen is
trash trapped yeah it's kind of find a
way to find a way to trap the queen but
it's like a self trap right it's one of
those puzzles where you have to
find a way to like self Checkmate or uh
so I guess travel Queen here so Knight
goes to D5 which makes a lot of sense to
me because we want to open this diagonal
so takes takes uh I was thinking about
ticks I don't think unfortunately this
tactic doesn't work because page four
but this looks extremely dangerous maybe
oh you want to do it the other way I was
thinking Bishop G6 first but maybe I
don't need to give up so you cannot take
this way because of the check and the
queen comes
yeah and Rook okay
yeah
it's enough to
so maybe this is your Bishop G7 right
yeah yeah I was thinking group F3 but
the idea is you cannot take this leads
to mate and but instead Bishop G7 and we
just collect everything
so for this reason he did not take so
this Knight actually needs to stay here
another goes to three Switching gears so
actually there's been a big changes in
the position right all the central pawns
came off
and the e-file is open and white has the
bishop pair so I think this bishop pair
can be really scary and especially by
this happy that this bishop is gone
right yeah I must say even though the
computer evaluates this position is
approximately equal I would prefer to
play with white just the open position
with the bishop error it's it always is
a nice feeling and he plays Bishop D6
preserve your Bishop because again
there's Rook H5 and you lose your H2
Pawn which is kind of hard to imagine
that in this position you can lose your
H2 Pawn instead he plays before and
inspired I guess the world playable
championship game he sacrifices an
exchange
Bishop F4
so he's playing for um
compensation here the rule goes back ah
so this Pawn is falling
um
oh so Bishop H2 is where is where things
went wrong so actually
um Christopher was playing like quite a
nice game okay at some moment maybe he
was much worse with some precise play by
white but he had some nice ideas and
then I guess Bishop H2 is it's not so
good because of G4 yeah
and wreckage too so he must have
overlooked this before move because it
brings
The Rook into the defense so he should
have taken this way and can I move my
Bishop somewhere just play for
compensation yeah and I have how many
pounds
sure opposite colored Bishops and my
Rook will come back probably going after
this Pawn but I think he can put this
one hang on to it white would really
like to play rookie seven here but I
think that runs into um
uh Queen D4 is what I was going to say
but maybe you can play Queen E3 there
and be okay because Queen F2 would fail
to Rook hitch one
but uh
Queenie Queen E3 I didn't see what the
Tactical shot was
um I think
it just goes Checkmate okay we're
covering this and you cannot Escape
because it just hangs either way wait so
that means you have to play Rook E3
after Queen D4 which that's real crime
yeah
F4
ah but if you take here I will take here
so something like this
and now this is hanging it's actually
funny this is not hanging right because
you have Knight G4 oh so we can even
take on C5 maybe so Queen C55
unfortunately oh yeah this position is
very loose I think black has to be very
precise to hang on to everything because
here even though I cannot tactically
take your pieces as of right now they're
still a bit loose yeah
yeah so very very tricky which is why
you would prefer to play Bishop H2
because
um from the persp uh from an attacking
perspective if we can move our Bishop
away the The Rook on H5 is a good
attacker I think yeah you just missed
this G4 idea with the uh discovered uh
attack on with the Rook on E2 but
surprisingly he's not just going to be
losing the Rook here he still has a
resource after Knight G4
and you pick up the other Rook but
unfortunately the Knight hangs and now
we will see how we got to the final
position
Queen B4 is nice just everything is
defended A3 is defended c5's defended
and we're rebooting the queen out of C3
starts checking 25
and if he went Queen D1
Queen E3
and
so this move is a bit annoying because
your your idea is to check me on this
diagonals and not allow me to go to C1
and I think if I check this oh yeah then
Queen G oh yeah yeah I was gonna say
queen G one to G2 but Queen F3 is a
simpler Fork sorry I
think I'm not really thinking C1 because
we'll go there
uh so what am I let's say you make a
move you're maybe trying to dominate the
queen like somehow with the King like
there's no Queen E3 anymore and if you
check me then King C3 is an improvement
what did you want to play sorry uh
Quincy through is interesting I think
you actually run into Perpetual because
you need this queen key square square
for your king can I push you
yeah I cannot go two three again queen
of six
so many Queen Forks so what do I do here
so here maybe I can
um
because if Queenie won after Queen G1
yeah this is very strong and if here I
can go oh
see everyone yeah okay once I got to
bebond I'm perfectly so if that's it
with my queen only one and then my queen
will go to C3
and that will be the end but he played
King D1 and queen E3 is actually a
really annoying move it's a quiet move
it's not a check so maybe you know
you're calculating checks and you're
like okay if he goes Queen H5 then
King C1 I ran away but then your
opponent makes a quiet move and now you
have to find a move because Queen C3 is
possible but runs into this and if
Queenie one here this Pawn hangs and if
you go King D2 then
it's hard to escape the checks yeah
and here actually
I have to be yeah yeah King D4 Queen F6
would be an unfortunate way to lose the
game
so white has to find some kind of a move
here he was thinking about
um A4 I don't know what you think about
that I have to take right yeah then my
point was maybe I can even
okay I was thinking about
taking on A6 but it's very scary
to do so
um because now you can go A3 or
something and I have to worry about
losing the game
so I don't like that so much so let's
try some checks
yeah I don't like I mean
this is a bit scary
yeah probably I shouldn't allow my
opponent so much counter play but what
else can we do we don't actually have
that many moves the spawn is hanging so
the queen it's a bit of a funniest looks
along here can I go here
but now I cannot run because you have
this check
yeah we have to return to protect the
bishop on E2 it's very unfortunate wow
this queen E3 what a resource wow so
even though objectively Christopher
might be losing Christopher
um so losing this game would put him out
of contention for first so he's he's
definitely fighting as hard as he can
even if the position objectively isn't
that good for him right now he has real
fighting chances and uh is trying to
make it to the playoffs yeah and I see
um yes sir he he looks a bit nervous I
think maybe he's realizing
he doesn't have too many moves in the
position actually actually he doesn't
because a lot of the moves were trying
to make hangs the pawn so the queen
actually cannot move
because if you go to C3 you run into
Perpetual if you go somewhere else I
take on C5 and then the fight starts all
over again I now have three pawns for
the
um for a piece and that's just a fight
and you just don't have too many moves
so I think A4 by process of elimination
might be the only move but I can sense
that he's a bit annoyed and Christopher
is up
35 minutes on the clock every day
Christopher's up 35 minutes on the clock
and uh he found a very important
defensive resource this kind of quiet
moves in this in this types of positions
are very annoying because you are when
you have this kind of exposed King
against the queen you're constantly
looking for checks you know like every
movie like okay I don't want a blunder a
Perpetual I don't want a blunder some
chick takes my pawn and then you
opponent makes a quiet woman you realize
oh I have to make a move and I don't
have a very comfortable one so I think
your A4 move might be
a bit forced and here we have to find
something
can I if you go here here
no I cannot push the spawn
yeah the same Queen G1 Queen G2 tactic I
think saved Black's life after C6
but this is scary oh it's terrifying
actually we're like a major risk of
losing the game I think Bishop C4 was
forced if we played a naive move like C6
on the previous turn then A2 and I I
don't see a way we save ourselves we
don't have any of the squares to
and here we're not going to Queen first
and let you take for the check right we
will check first and then clean our Pawn
because move ordering chess is very very
important but okay while um yeah sir
quesada Perez is thinking about this
position uh do you want to go ahead and
take a look at the B parents yeah
clean and our key matchup of the day is
of course Felix blubberger who's playing
with the black pieces all he needs is a
draw and our second important matchup
will be his closest rival Jensen Liang
versus Mr michalowski because if Jason
loses then it doesn't matter what
happens in Felix's game so let's start
with Felix's game and let's start with
the current position and let's start by
evaluating what is going on so what do
you think about this position there
seems to be a lot of Peace tension a lot
of pieces are hanging and hopefully
hopefully nothing is losing by force
here yeah so my first thought is that
black is very active but this uh this
deep Pawn
um does offer white some long-term uh
long-term possibilities so
um
uh yeah I guess this Knight F this
Knight F5 uh move that we were looking
at before the broadcast black is just
safe because of Queen takes G3 and Rook
takes D3 which is kind of important
otherwise the position would be
unplayable and uh if Knight takes uh
sorry if Bishop takes F5 then uh I had
blundered Hood Knight 92 before the
broadcast so don't blunder this one so
it'd be an unfortunate Fork so
tactically he's able to hang on to his
position
his plate attacking
attacking this Rook so I expect Rook D3
so what is the idea here Knight F5 and
after Knight F5 Queen F5
where does The Rook go I think the Roku
goes to D4 I can go to D2 but on D4 my
Rook is more secure ah this actually is
a nice tactic because if rookie one
find a tactic it's a quiz like Queen G5
up to the task
very very cool so some background issues
of course and if you take I simply take
and the coin is not touchable because of
background mate
so Rook D2 is very tempting and kind of
movie might play in a Blitz game
actually in a Blitz game you should play
Rook D4 because it's just more secure
safe yeah it defends your rook and now
my next move is just Queen d8 no matter
what
for example rookie one Queen d8 and we
have one where heavy fish end game but
this Pawn is actually I think is falling
I don't see how you will defend it I'm
not threatening to take it this move but
my move is G6 I'm starting to kick your
queen away and open
um a window for my king what do you call
it Loft
and take this D5 pawn and you cannot put
your Rook behind it this looks very
awkward and this looks like
this looks like something will fall here
so I think rookie won Rook D1 could be
an issue for you like Rook uh so you
have to calculate at least like rookie
five Rook D1 can F2 Queen H4 and uh if
you go to E1 then Queen E1 is made and
if you go G3 then I think Queen H2 uh
can E3 Queen D2 is also leading to mate
very quickly how many minutes do I have
one two that's what I think yeah enough
there's there's a good number
unfortunately only two checkmates in one
yeah this is dangerous but
but if you hang on to this Pawn
so Queen G5 is played I don't see any
other move besides Rook D3 can I no this
doesn't make sense because
this is an exchange sacrifice completely
unnecessary and
there's nothing else right something
like this doesn't make sense because
then I take on F5 yeah
so this line is forced maybe you can
start with rookie one here
can I go uh no I think the ish oh no I
was going to say something really really
stupid I was gonna say queen takes D6
would be good because if rookie 8 then
Queen f8 I have too many pieces but you
have Queen d8 Checkmate so positionally
I might be doing well but the game just
ends you just need one more move yeah so
can I go F6 here
no
it's unfortunate
um
I was gonna say Bishop e
no it's it's yeah Bishop E6 and it takes
then I take on D6 but oh Knight E8
Knight E8 was there can I do this
all right this uh bar is going crazy at
his part no you're right 98 was very
strong here very geometric
and there is no way to defend I played
this exact tactic recently which was
against like a 1700 but you played it so
you weren't already no I played 98 okay
against uh just in one of our local
tournaments
okay so what do we do here if rookie one
we have Bishop D7 doesn't feel right
yeah
I'm Gonna Keep Falling for the same
tactic
yeah and the idea is again you cannot
take so okay I think this is the danger
in the position
wrong because I see pieces coming off
the board so moves have been played
um so maybe H6
oh yeah H6 is a good version because
yeah you would like to play Queen F5 but
unfortunately it's defended by the 904
and everything just sort of comes
together process of elimination is our
friend yeah because here I think either
98 or queen of six is scary again
if you let us try every single move
eventually we'll find the right one
wait
some upper night and rookie 8 is mate
but what can I do G6
is good enough and if here between this
seven yeah I think who defended everyone
it is defended next move I will take
even if you go a G4 I can't save my
knight but even this should be oops yeah
I mean it's a major piece on gaming once
again the king is the keynote G1 is not
very safe
um so this is where we had it I expect
him to take on F5 although I imagine he
doesn't have to but no I think he has to
ride this is made I don't think
it's also possible but I don't I don't
think I like this
because now yeah I really don't want to
move my F Pawn because as you're
pointing out Queen E6 followed by
Queenie it could be I just have to
calculate all the checks and I uh I hate
calculation
yeah I also don't like this
um
because rookie1 Queen d8 has to be
played now check you have to play King
f8
but somehow we are actually safe here
like
if we take we have to take with our Rook
crate because Queen no actually maybe we
can't play Queen D5 Queen D5 Queen C it
we have Queen d8 which saves us it's
going to take care but maybe a queen D4
Queen E3 was my big idea but then it's
perpetual yeah but he's more than happy
with a Perpetual yeah so the idea is if
you check me I can never go on the
e-file because you take it with a check
so 23 looks annoying this also looks
very annoying right no
does not look annoying because we get we
get it
yeah ah but I know it looks annoying
Queen E5 no
25 because now we're covering H5
oh
nice it's a better version of Queen E3
so there's no more Perpetual it's just I
just need like three moves and then
eventually eventually I find a good move
once I blunder attack me the piece of
thermal is for Golden right yeah but I
don't know I don't know I'm gonna play
F6 yeah me me either so what is the
current position so this is the current
position so here's a decision so this is
made so you can either take on F5 or
throw in this F6 F6 so this is going to
be his decision we can go back and see
how we got here
so a nimsa
okay it's called the uh so E3 name so
I've faced the specialty two movies
specialty to move is so annoying
I have faced all of this 92 what the
idea is eventually with
they take with the Knight and they play
this
um I think there are some
there's some Fabiana has played this
line yeah I see it against Levon I think
this was in the American Cup
I'm not super familiar with these these
positions from either color I avoid the
nimso with uh with white and I've been a
lifetime Queens game with decline player
so the whole point is you don't when
they take on C3 you're not compromising
your structure so you're not taking with
the B Pawn and then you wait for them to
play B6 and then you go D5 so it's just
some minor ways to annoy
um to annoy black so for example if
you're immediately take then this is not
a great structure for you right and my
knight from G1 went to city which is a
good square and maybe it's a good
version of this banana-like structures
but at the same because we traded a lot
of pieces but at the same time we can't
really take on D5 because I'm going to
take with a piece
I was going to say it reminds me of a
benoni but like not a very good benoni
because usually in the benoni you have
this G6 and monster Bishop on G7 and
black doesn't I don't see the
compensation for the space deficit
so instead of D5 which is the critical
line he went F3 so this got traded D6
Knight C6 and now D5
so the Knight went back
and now take on D5 I understand what you
mean about this bishop but one of the
problems for black in the benoni is the
lack of space benoni and Bengal Gambit
which I used to play a lot I used to
lose a lot with uh the well in Bangkok
Gambit actually black does have a lot of
compensation but in this panoni kind of
structures the one of the problems is
lack of space right because pieces don't
get traded and white will have this kind
of really nice Center so black is really
struggling for space and the modern
pieces you trade when you don't have
space the better it is for you so the
fact that some pieces have come off the
board is quite helpful for black the
problem is yes I would much rather have
this bishop on G7 but
uh there's a lot of counter play
associated with most like a6b5
and in the game he plays immediate
Knight F5 which is against the move E4
so if you go E4 my knight is Happy on D4
oh I was thinking you would try quid H4
and here is tactically it doesn't work
out but in general I would like if my
knight just lands on D4 I'm so happy
because this never happens in a
non-structure yeah I've never seen an
ion D4 like that in the structure
black would be very happy so this is
very concrete so castles and rookie it
again going after this Pawn tempting him
to go E4 and putting a knight on D4
and even if I trade and then put a
bishop on A6 quite happy I think even if
I put a bishop on D7 because so many
pieces have come off black is quite
comfortable here
so instead white sacrifice is a pawn
and this is how we're starting to get
close to our positions yeah Sam Sam
shanklin's in his uh in his book um
small steps to Giant Improvement like
talked about benoni structures and he he
said um
uh benoni positions with four pieces on
the board are lost but the known any
positions with three pieces on the board
is better for white and then two pieces
should be should be about equal so um so
I don't know if you according to Sam Sam
shanklin's book I think that we might
have we might have equalized
no I
like those pieces humans minor pieces
minor pieces yeah no that makes a lot of
sense that's a that's a very logical way
of thinking about it because minor
pieces they fight for the same squares
and then
like you have very limited number of
squares for your pieces so when you have
a lot of them they just kind of step on
each other toes so it's better to trade
them but here this is actually very
concrete because white has given up a
pawn but he is playing against
lack of development and trying to create
some problems in the position
so the Knight goes to D4 so one of the
ways of playing is to take take and take
but
I think he was afraid of
um this bishop Ken going on Bishop h
uh
I didn't see this
and is this a
Perpetual question mark it is right
uh yeah yeah I don't think he can go for
Adventures here
your rookie Yates and quindy too it's a
queen E3 I meant this is a nice meet
yeah
so something like this looks scary so
instead he went 94. he just wants to
take this Pawn
so Bishop F5 black wants to develop and
queen C7 and we reach this position so
there's a lot of Peace tension so it
works out really well for black because
of this pin and gives black the much
needed Tempo to finish his development
because here black is threatening Bishop
D3 so in this position
this was not possible because
and we're going to see 98 again can now
meet here made here all kinds of
checkmates so it doesn't work out
so black cannot give up this E8 file
because this e file because if we look
at this all of White's pieces are in the
game and your Rook is on A8 right so
it's like
um basic concept of Chess that you need
to bring their pieces into the game
so instead he plays Queen C7 and
I think especially with modern tests
we're learning that tactics
uh supersede everything else if you can
make something work tactically then it
just works it's just how it is in chess
you know tactics is just over everything
you can make some positional judgment
but at the end of the day if if you lose
a piece you lose a piece and that
matters more
and he ate this happened and now we're
reaching the
precise move
to hold the balance in the position
yeah the current position is Knight F5
right and he hasn't moved yet
um so this is the current position so he
must be deciding between taken Knight F5
is calculating making sure his back rank
doesn't hang so of course F6 does give
your king a loft but at the same time a
bit of a weakness
and Knight F5 you have to make sure
you're not getting made it on the back
rank but I simply do not take do not see
any other moves because I'm just
threatening meat great yeah I think F6
and Knight of five are the only two
moves and it must be very nice to be in
Felix's shoes right now because he gets
to press this position as black and he
only needs a draw to secure uh first
place in this tournament speaking of
which would you like to look at the
Jason Leanne game against Victor
mikhilevski let's take a look at that
because if michalevski wins this as he
is up a queen in this position that I
just pulled up then uh Felix can just do
whatever he wants because uh thanks to
Victor he will secure the match the
tournament Victory so what do we have
here it's a queen versus two Miners and
a pawn
so he was michalevsky was on the other
end of this a few rounds ago right he
had
a rook against Felix actually yeah yeah
it must feel good to be on the on the
receiving end of this in Felix's
tournament determined by two positions
two yeah two games by michalevsky once
against himself and one against Lane
probably so actually if he wins this
then he did the most to help Felix right
because he lost to him and then he's
beating his competitor so this is the
most you can do for someone in a
tournament so what is going on in this
position so is there a compensation I
mean okay so the spawns are moving so
there's that
um two minor pieces I mean White's
position looks kind of solid right
nothing is falling apart yet yeah so
what can I do can I try to clean this
Pawn
yeah I like that I like that move yeah
with your queen E1 Queen F2 idea not
even just to Queen the pawn but just
it's pointing out that the king safety
matters Like Queenie one here anyway
instead of rookie and if you take on E3
then I can play Rook takes D4
okay this is problematic and yeah so if
you take this you actually lose both of
your pieces
like Checkers yeah and then the pound
two at the end and uh yeah Queen after
is actually very strong yeah you have to
go for this right because queen of two
is winning a piece yeah but at the same
time this position just looks completely
over right like rookie 8 Keen F7 and
then you take on D4 I take uh yeah
take with the cane I was a little I like
hallucinated I was like you can't play
Queen takes because Knight D6 but that
would be cheating
so you can probably take with other
piece
it takes here but
G6 oh it's Queen C3 also yeah
I want to win this Pawn and Coin my Pawn
Yeah and the key is you want to keep
your queen and king on opposite color
squares so you don't get forked by that
or you keep your king away from your
queen and then you don't have to worry
about it a sad way you could lose this
is why you could play C6 and then you
take it and they play Bishop B5 and then
takes Knight D6 so don't put your Canaan
coin on the same color bad things will
happen to you this is a very study like
thing right because you see some kind of
those domination ones that black has to
take and then you do this but of course
yeah I've done one or two casparian
puzzles in my day
so this is the fun ction that we have
and it's plug small
decisive game from this tournament and
actually in his fighting Spirit might
just decided the tournament before the
leader is even done with his game I
think he's enjoying this position it's
like oh so many so many good moves here
let's take a look at how we got here
so Knight F35 D4 Knight F6 and we have a
rogozin a very sharp line we'll say this
is like quite I would not have predicted
this opening for mehalevski because we
saw this English line like quite a few
times with uh this Knight F6 E5 and he's
playing the regosan I would have thought
that he would be like a grunfeld player
because against the English specifically
he was playing Knight of six G6 so it's
uh it's interesting to note that maybe
he plays like a variety of different
openings
yeah definitely because we see him in
future to his Bishop against the English
every game and here he goes for this
line so Bishop B4 E3 E3 is a bit more of
a quieter line there's Bishop G5 lines
too
so but now we're starting to transition
uh into those nimso right because I
played this position before I get
tricked in the names a lot so you can
get to this position from Bishop D2 or
E3 Bishop D2 and yeah
exit three Bishop B4
interior let's say castle Knight F3 D5
and C5 in the first game I saw played in
this line was by uh Wesley so I think
Wesley so had some nice game here as
white
or maybe I must remembered cardiac can
beat so I don't know
uh this line gets played lots of not
players they
started with C5 to
some lines
so I think what was it Bishop D3 D5 here
you can take on no sorry
it's like cdcd some lines like this
oops that's the CD
but okay let's go back to our game so
it's possible to get so there's a lot of
transpositions in chess in the opening
so we got this position traditional
order so I very similar to the other
game we're looking at with this bishop
c380 and Knight E4 and now Rook C1 so
White's main idea here is not to allow
the structure
which is also a possibility these are
all lines
but
um yeah this feels like what black wants
though right like black would would take
on C4 play like Knight D7 Queen C7 and
B6 and play for like dark Square
domination I've seen some old games
where they used to play this way with
black
yeah this bishop trade actually like is
something black is happy with because in
a lot of the structures when this
happens there's a bishop on C1 and
Knight on F6 so of course this structure
with the bishop is quite a bit but there
is this long-term potential and at some
point if this bishop ever opens this
bishop just becomes a monster and there
is a dark Square Bishop to play against
it so this bishop just dominates and it
also this is a lot of moves for white to
play Bishop D2 Bishop C3 just to allow
the structure again so the whole point
is to go Rook C1
and after take take the whole idea is
you take with the rook and you get the C
file this is actually a really funny
position right because if I compare the
queen side to the king size black has
developed their King side and very
quickly and castled and white has
exclusively developed their Queen side
yeah I think the argument as to why why
it would be better is that the king side
not being developed probably doesn't
matter as much if Queens come off the
board and queens come off the board
um very often in these lines because you
might want to have your cane in the
center and the end game as opposed to
castled
so for example if Knight C6 no you're
actually in some positions you have to
worry about this because I might take
and go before and just be like
um you know I took your pawn and then
you take
um extremely happy I developed my bishop
and to stop upon and you have no
compensation because I just got before
and another key aspect of this kind of
positions and this is in Queen's Gambit
declined to you want to wait for this
bishop to move so you take on C4 so the
bishop doesn't develop to C4 in one move
so you wait for them to waste the move
and then you take on C4 and then it's
black you claim you've gained the move
so for this reason black took on D4
Knight takes doesn't want to end up with
an isolated Pawn
[Music]
E5 Knight goes to F3 and he says take my
Pawn
and actually this is a it's a funny idea
I think this is uh emphasizes my point
more than the previous position because
there is zero development on the king
side so there's only one Rook that is
out and for black all the pieces are in
the back rank right this is uh you know
it's not something you show to your
beginner students and be like this is
how it just works yeah no I would I
would shy away from showing this to any
student under 1800 yeah it's very tricky
showing these games to your students so
F5 with the idea to just go F4 and ask
white how you're developing so it goes
F4
A5 see this is another move you cannot
show to your students
Knight goes to D7 so the idea is what is
the idea maybe bring the Rook somehow or
put a pollinate for
honey if I like how you just gives up a
pawn and displays so calmly and position
domination that's how he was playing
against the English he was more than
happy to give away his epon just to play
for compensation a mikhilevski has a
very fighting like um Dynamic style it
feels like it feels like he he really
likes the initiative and likes to even
if objectively he might be worse he he's
more than happy to play with the
initiative and try to outplay his
opponents
yeah definitely and I have to say when
you're playing not knowing the
evaluation of the position maybe you
think you're like okay I'm worse but you
know and you know the eval tells you
you're much better that you know it
really influences our thing thinking for
sure right because once the eval changes
like when it goes up or down crazy when
we know there's something in a position
but sometimes in a game we don't always
know I like actually now imagine
understanding what he did so his whole
idea is this domination he wants to put
a piece on D5 he's playing against this
bishop and this Knight and we saw a game
yesterday in group a where I think it
was Jacob when his night was on E1 and
couldn't move and here also we see this
Knight is stuck here
yeah it's a very entertaining style like
after uh B5 he just gives another Pawn
for the D5 Square he doesn't care about
material at all all he wants to do is
maximize his peace Mobility so the
problem so this is actually tactical now
because if you move your Rook this is uh
okay of course I move my Rook on the
board Square on purpose just to show
this is a threat and you cannot move
your Rook anywhere to protect the square
so white has to give up on Exchange so
it's a matter are you going to give up
this rook and this rook and because we
were looking at this game before the
broadcast we know that he made the wrong
decision he won Queen C1 and he gave up
this rook and tactically this was a
mistake so it would have been better
you know in inspired by today's match to
give up this rook and have this very
strong Rook on C5
and after take we can throw in a check I
think actually throwing a check is quite
accurate so stop Bishop from developing
yeah and King goes to h8 and you know
does background issues potentially and I
can't take either way I think this
problem is most logical and if I could
somehow put my knight on E3 and just
push it up one square yeah I'll be very
happy with uh yeah like Bishop takes
quite a bit because um the bishop on G2
wasn't doing very much because Black's E
and F pawns were sort of blunting on the
diagonal and now the bishop is going to
protect the B5 pawn and everything's
like kinda safe and secure for white so
it's a it's a rook and two pawns oh
sorry it's a it's an exchange for two
pawns and a knight but I think that
White's pawns are moving uh kind of fast
and what I like about this C5 Rook then
you just blocking the C file right
because if they play Bishop B7
not there come and take then I think
I'll be happy to take this way and then
go C6 and I have two connected past
pawns you're more than happy and maybe
at some point you know I can go Knight
C3 take this Pawn too and then all of a
sudden I have the entire Queen side you
have a pass Pawn here but
I think I prefer to have the Queens off
so I never have to worry about things
like E3 Queen D5 so my king is safe so
yeah this would have been a better
version unfortunately he gave up this
rook and this ran like tactically and I
think even optically he probably thought
about this position that okay I'm gonna
have connected past one but I'm
fortunate for him tactically things
don't work out because of this queen B6
really nice move and it looks like it's
impossible to hang on to every Pawn
you cannot push the spawn because of the
PIN
you cannot push this Pawn because this
one hangs and Rook C8 is coming so if
you play something like King H1 and
you're like I want to go D5 next move
doesn't work out
yeah so just tactically again maybe
positionally this looks really nice but
tactically just by one move it's not
working out so Queen goes to C2 Rook
this one to C8 which makes more sense
because you defend this guy too
and takes on B5 and now I'm going to
block your pawns and I have the B file
so this is just very strong for black
so it goes Rook B1
so let's see how we got to the position
Bishop goes to F1 I want to see how he
won the queen
or
ah you cannot move your horse
this is unfortunate
so you went Rook C3 Rook B1
oh this is a big problem because if you
take I take E2 is hanging
and if you go Rook D2 then E3 and
um
yeah you can probably just take E2 and
take D4 or oh you just want to take D4
straight off and I want to see if this
is mate it might be
pretty close yeah Knight F3 you just
move away
with your rook and Bishop H3 is coming
with devastation
oh
that's very nice yeah Rook D4 strong
idea
and if you go rookie 3 then I just take
and if you
know C4 standing with with Chuck all
right just take only two here yeah I
don't need to be fancy I cannot take
with the bishop
yeah ripped and then we managed to trade
Rooks and these exchange down positions
where there's a like Jester Rook versus
a minor like pure end game they're
always super unpleasant to deal with
because the Rook somehow becomes so much
stronger I don't want to put my keen on
F7 yay I just thought this is so funny
because your Rook just has no way of
getting behind the pawn yeah of course
here please put this behind and as you
were saying this is just dominating yeah
so the king will come to the square and
The Rook will start collecting pawns
yeah we see everybody's sacrifice uh
exchanges these days but
um that's usually for like some sort of
concrete compensation uh if you make it
to the end game the The Exchange will
actually matter
so he played Queen V3 and
what's the idea here
let's go back
or why not queen bee I liked your E3
move a lot more yeah well not here
actually oh man
there's nowhere right it's not yet I see
three yeah I don't I don't want to hate
my queen so easily but Queen B2 I want
to play it because Rook takes D4 is a
tactical threat I think Queen letter B2
and yeah my ideas Rook takes D4 although
here now maybe C7 yeah
so C6 but um
uh
uh can I go Rook C8 and then D5 I'm not
threatening anything oh you won just
Queen D2 yeah it's very simple right you
see a pass plan you put your piece
behind it I don't want you to make new
Queens
so wait we have seen more moves and he
won Queen B2 so this is bad news from
miloski copy in my move so I mean with
four minutes against Jason's nine
minutes so let's go back to the Felix
game and see if we have oh we have a lot
of development so this game is headed to
the draw territory so we might just have
a winner here okay no no I take this
back I don't want to do this so he took
and he won rookie three so he doesn't
give up he doesn't want to keep up the
the file
the e-file
yeah I think he's just trying to
minimize risk like Rook D4 maybe he
would have played in earlier runs of the
tournament but right now he's just
trying to secure first place which makes
sense because they are playing for quite
a bit of money
so Queenie I love Queen E5 because and
this force is a queen trade because if
you get adventurous you actually are
running into very nice mate because of
the pawn and F3 instead of any other
kind of Loft
so after Queen E8 this happened and this
is a past spawn but the problem with
this kind of past month is once the King
goes to D6 this Pawn will fall and the
another problem is when you push a pass
pound too far then your opponent just
comes around and just crawls it right
because you only have a rook defending
it and you're putting it too close to
where my pieces are
so this exchange happened a five takes
takes these six can get paid and I
imagine he's gonna go
Rook D5 rook d8 and we will reach move
40 and this game if this happens
definitely we'll reach move 40 and the
game will end in a draw he plays D7
so rook d8 and I'm assuming Rook D5
right and then we'll probably just trade
our a pawn for the d-pawn and again this
3v3 Rook end game is nothing nothing too
special for for white or black so very
likely this game is going to end very
very quickly they just need to make
until move 40 so by the rules of the
tournament they can agree to a draw
but in our group a we have a lot of
important games going oh my God I just
got so scared because I clicked on it
and this was the position that we're
analyzing and I thought there is a queen
so let's see where we are oh no the C5
Pawn is gone so let's see how we got
here let me promote this variation so I
can get to it so when we left off this
very annoying we need to remove bikes
Christopher was played Queen one two A5
few more checks
actually King went all the way to the
king side that's
wait I'm curious why because he wants to
take the pawn with the check
says okay either take a Perpetual or
give me your Pawn with a check and he
gave the pawn with a check ah there's
more checks
do I okay I can get out of checks I can
go to A1 right yeah if you check I go to
A2 now that the C Pawn has disappeared
um okay
obviously white is still the one playing
for a win but the tide is definitely
definitely turned I think Christopher
has taken a lot of the danger out of the
position and um he is trying his best to
make it to the playoffs all thing needs
to do is survive you just need to have a
point if you somehow thrives and he wins
then he gets clear first but it's very
hard to see how he wins here unless
white really over pushes it you know
like if white gets to a point when it's
already a drone he has to admit it's a
job but he just thinks okay I have to
keep playing for a win and somehow the
tie turns but
the last move I actually made for
um Yasser I don't for Christopher
whether I don't love this move because I
don't see how you defend this but maybe
you can start pushing let's say there is
a world where Christopher wins this game
like this H Pawn could be very strong
and then you have some very sharp Queen
in game at the end but it does feel like
okay if white doesn't want to lose white
is never going to lose this end game
at least at some point
out with all my pieces on the light
squares and just plug the spawn and
again okay F5 is not possible here let
me try something like this
let's say you did this just to show an
idea something like this can be very
scary because now your king might end up
in danger but we do know that
Christopher has an experience of playing
this kind of end game because it's very
similar to what he had not very similar
but somewhat similar to what he had
against mystery in round one yeah so at
this you know it's experience in this
position I think a lot of the danger in
this position for black comes from the a
pawn like in that final position I think
white might have just been winning
because of A4 A5 A6 and I I don't think
there's a good way of stopping that idea
yeah it's not so easy to push this kind
of Pawns because even if you go G5 G4 G3
it's the one diagonal right so you have
to push your Pawns in a way that you're
also blocking my bishop and uh pieces of
Peace yeah so here I think he has to
defend either F6 or D6 and maybe now A4
with the idea of
but I have to calculate if taking on A6
is actually taking an X looks very scary
right
Maybe
thanks
but Bishop takes are gonna start
defeating me for or something like this
maybe I need to come
I'd like yeah H5 and I don't know well
it needs to be a little scared I think
so Queen D6 was played we can turn on
our eval
slightly better for white not what he
wanted and I think again going back this
big mistake was King D1
because I think King D2 just made life
so much easier because this key King
City move because your queen can go to
D4 in this position
and uh defending the pawn and in this
position I actually yeah and Yasser
wants to make it to the uh playoffs as
well and he needs to win this game to do
so so they're both fighting for a
potential first place here yeah this is
a big fight this uh going to so it
doesn't matter this is like a
championship game right because it
doesn't matter what happens if
Christopher wins his Champion if he
draws his player for him is Yasser wins
he goes into a playoffs so this is
crucial for outstandings another game
that is crucial for our standings is
taro versus
Darda oh wow that's a lot of fun
and one of the pants is on A7 so my
first reaction is completely winning for
white with a great analysis right I look
at like three extra pounds he must be
winning four wide but even if I lose
this A7 Pawn
this must be winning am I dropping
um I mean it's always scary with horses
right they'll jump they jump pretty
pretty fast but also I think if you lose
an exchange you're probably still
winning like Rook a19 A2 Rook A2 there's
that end game looks really bad for black
but obviously you never you never do
that
so so this has to be a win for him oh
he's playing on incremental soil uh time
pressure so 23 seconds versus one minute
so Rook E3 played if I'm not mistaken if
Dara wins this game he also makes it to
a playoff so we could have quite a few
players tying for first in this
tournament yeah and I was reading the
regular
up to a four-way tie and then what
happens if there's a bigger tie I I'm
not sure so if it's a more than two
player tie if it's three or four they
will play around Robin ten plus two and
if there's a clear winner then we have a
clear winner and if there's a tie then
they will play a blitz and if that's a
tie then there's an Armageddon so at
some point
there will be a winner but that'll all
happen today so no matter what there
will be a winner in this tournament
after this round oh eight is very nice
because if you play Rook 8 then we will
trade and take out D1 if you play Bishop
eight we will take on a with our rook
and then take on D1 and now it won't
won't just be three pawns for nothing
it'll be two pieces for a rook and two
pawns which
nice move
and you're getting a lot of moves in so
he got time he got a minute 44 seconds
for seven moves I think Darda will play
because whenever you're playing in um
you're reaching time control and you
have minutes or seconds you just play
until time control because what's the
difference I mean if you have 30 minutes
on the clock you don't want to sit there
and suffer through this position but
when you have no time at that point
there's nothing to lose G5 is actually a
very nice move because if you try to get
active with your Rook then I get active
with my knight and my knight goes to D5
and from D5 so for example if you do
something like this
um maybe I'm going away from everything
so from the bishop diagonal from Forks
I'm just going away so now the and then
you can play King G1 you can just play
very solid the rule comes here you put
your Bishop back so we're just putting
our Bishop from the on the the original
squares one by one but this Knight is so
dominant this bishop helps C4 stops Rook
G2 check and I will eventually start
pushing the spawns and you might even
take my kingside pods oh you wanna go
something like this no I mean like
because
F6 yeah
that is also very possible
and even
that'd be very quick Victor said he goes
G5 and then Dara is like you cannot go
to the second rank
and but now isn't he losing a pawn here
so here if you go here then I go here
yeah luckily I think you're up enough
material it shouldn't really matter like
maybe just F4 to try to simplify
like um but you don't want to simplify
it too much
you know yeah
like f word
that's not I can put a bishop on it
okay
yeah
I mean it's a past one I want to keep a
password the reason I'm keeping this one
is because it's on the light square and
the Bishop from F1 can easily defend it
which will free my Rook
and then next uh I will play here I will
defend I will I want to play as safe as
possible you know my pieces are
defending each other nothing is loose
and then I slowly bring my knight now my
Rook is free to join the game and
um like if you try to activate you know
like something like this then I will put
my Bishop here and just like move Square
y Square I'm slowly moving up but I just
don't want to hang anything because I
don't want to get to a position where
it's some kind of a rook versus Bishop
Knight and a pawn which should be
winning but you know somehow
you can run into some kind of tricks so
I I like how he's playing very safe but
I think Rook A4 is a very reasonable try
yeah I I think your Rook A4 move is
probably the best way to try to continue
the position we can also hang on to this
Pawn so we can start with this move and
then hang on to this pawn it doesn't
matter which one I just want my Bishop
to defend it just so the rest of my
pieces can activate
and if I can get or here maybe I can do
things
can I do things tactically yeah here I
can maybe hang on tactically right yeah
Knight C4 defense backwards that's that
was my original idea unfortunately there
is a check I mean even this as you
mentioned should be good but um I don't
like the adventures yeah I wasn't
yeah my intention was to go F4 to try to
um keep the material balance the same
but maybe tactically it doesn't work out
like F4 if you take on F4 then I play
Knight F4 now B4 is no longer available
to you because Knight D5 but um maybe
you start with rip before and then I
take on G5 and when when you take
um
yeah now this end game becomes sorry I
wanted to go Bishop D5 and yeah this
looks actually very strong yeah this is
also very strong
now that I see Bishop 25 I'm happier
than a bishop one F1 and then the
knights will check from somewhere at
this point will move this also looks
very strong he played with Rook B2 in
the game
and Rook p8 I expect him to go B5
because at this point it makes more
sense to defend this Pawn so you don't
lose P4 with a tampon then C4 right so I
think this makes sense
so the repeat was played so I think he
will go for this and now maybe
yes a four move I think in these sorts
of end games it's import important to
point out the reason why you said uh
taking B4 with the tempo is uh you don't
want to trade Rooks with white I think
that the side the defending side when
you're playing with a rook against two
pieces you would rather have one Rook
against two pieces as opposed to two
Rooks against Rook Bishop at night yeah
I think
definitely going to F1 so it's a matter
of what do I want to do with this Pawn
am I doing this with a knight only four
or am I going to F4 or am I not touching
this pawns I like I like the idea of
bish like G4 and the Knight E4
eventually I think that if we manage to
achieve all that we should be
technically winning
I mean I think this position is just
can you try to somehow dominate my
I mean it's easy to dominate at night
right maybe G4 here yeah could we start
with G4 instead of playing Knight F2 or
was there were you concerned about
something no I was just making moves
like here here okay so F5 is not
possible so what did I play I played
uh did I play this yeah I did play this
so just G4 here and Rook a three
but now we can go Rook D2 right
and now there's no Rook D3 and now
if I get my knight to E4 I'm feeling a
lot more comfortable about the position
because I'm targeting F6 and G5 and
everything is somehow protected yeah I
mean this is this is a dream I think we
have a lot of moves in the game yeah so
nothing was said what was played
so instead what was played he went
oh wow
all right he's just going for the queen
size ponds
so
oh
so major update
um Felix blauberger has actually drawn
his game and that means he uh he has won
the tournament he has won the B group of
the spring chess classic congratulations
to Felix blauberger it's a four thousand
dollar first place prize
um he definitely definitely deserves
that he played some very nice games
along the way to uh to achieve this
and what happened in the game is what we
expected move 40 the games end and uh
yeah very good tournament by him but he
before this round his performance I
checked was 26 90 something so almost at
2700 performance so this job will bring
him down maybe to 26.50
still a very very strong tournament he
might win the section by a point and a
half actually which is uh a dominant
performance an excellent performance and
I believe if you win group a you get
invited to group if you're in group b
you get invited to group a
and you know so next year he might be
playing in the other group which is uh
well not next year
um next Classic this year yeah yeah he
looks quarter potentially you can't get
you know he if he's able to play at a
future time play a group a which you
know there's a stronger competition so
there will be really good for his chess
career so a huge congratulations to him
a young player and winning four thousand
dollars for his efforts so very good
trip so far for him and we'll get him
for an interview and we will get to chat
with him get his impressions of this
tournament and of his games and about
his future plans
and this game between Jason Liang and
michalevsky a lot of moves have happened
so if we look at this position we left
off we saw all of this
and instead he started bringing his King
so he gave up this Pawn as well Punk
reaches E3
did not take because he didn't want to
lose this Pawn
instead he chose to defend it
[Music]
um
I think the final position white has
actually made a lot of progress in in
not losing this game I think that
Black's task has become a lot more
difficult even if objectively he still
lost these um these pawns are like kind
of hard to take and everything is kind
of kind of solid
yeah I think there's the huge problem of
King F3 and rookie seven so I'm actually
wondering if King E4 is a possibility
because this would be a really funny
development you have two pieces and king
and the Stefan but unfortunately this
runs
yeah because if you don't have this like
in this position
want it because these funds are actually
quite strong but so there's a fight for
second place so Jason actually is
fighting for his life here and for
second place but uh let's go back to
group a because
this is where things get decided so in
this thorough game we have reached move
for white so Daryl has reached time
control and Daniel has seconds left and
this game actually looks pretty decisive
because
oh this is actually
oh this is a really funny oh my God that
would be that would be an unfortunate
way to not get into the playoffs uh
speaking of which there's some breaking
news
um ilionic has drawn Nordic yakubayov
which means that on uh he will not make
it to the playoffs I don't think either
player uh qualify to the playoffs
unfortunately for them qualified to
playoffs you need plus one and
elianuznick has run all his games so
he's at 50 percent and Jacob lost an
important game yesterday to Yasser so he
is out of contention for first place
but let's go back to this download game
because
let's because we have a important game
here and a lot of moves have been played
let's see how we got here so he gave up
this pawn and he went for the other Pawn
so defense and defense so Daryl the
strong player that he is doesn't run
into Checkmate he played Bishop H3
yeah the idea of putting the bishop here
and then bringing not gonna lie to you I
could see myself playing King H3 in time
trouble yeah but the good thing
before then you can realize it's weird
so you can go King H4 yeah probably this
is what would happen to me and then I
would have some I I may win I may not
win but it would be it would be a fight
yeah this would be some work I don't
think a lot because this king is far
away but he just wants to take this Pawn
for free
and I don't quite see how you can defend
this this king is so far away this King
is
where does it go let's say we go to d8 I
go Bishop Here and Now King H3 is very
strong and your G4 move doesn't doesn't
work anymore because the King has a has
a way out so Bishop G4 Rook H Rick H7
King G2 is a square
Bishop H3 played and since we did reach
time control I don't know how long this
game will go on because as we mentioned
when you're in time travel you just play
right when you play it's our market and
time travel there's not much to lose it
just make your moves here with time
control but once you have the time when
you look at this position this has
happened to me sometimes I looked at my
position I just thought I don't want to
play this anymore and like my position
is too disgusting I don't want to Define
I just don't want to have to deal with
this game anymore and I just resign so
it's very likely we'll have a four-way
playoff right there's going to be a
Darius rietz
and uh one of one of Yasser or uh Yasser
quesada Prez or Christopher you
um should be in that and also our uh two
leaders going into the round will be in
the playoff but I think some Sevilla can
also join them if he wins and he's
playing another end game this episode
two Pawn
yeah the playoff procedures is going to
be a rapid round robin for uh three or
four players a game of 10 minutes with a
two second delay uh Blitz round robin if
uh winner if a clear winner is not
determined uh within the rapid round
robin and uh once again uh if a winner
is not determined out of the blitz round
robin then Armageddon games will uh will
be played if necessary
actually let's uh let's see our group A
standings again so we can see how what
kind of a tie break we're going to have
because so far
we have Benjamin and clador at five and
all of this considering that Christopher
is not going to win so this is after
round eight so we don't have the round
nine results so now we have glitter and
buck with Five Points potentially
Christopher joined them with Five Points
so there'll be three Savion can join
them and
um Dara can join them so we can have
half of the tournaments tied for first
at plus one so this is a very highly
tightly contested tournament and because
the players
are so strong and their ratings are so
close to each other we saw a lot of
draws but of course a lot of the draws
were fighting draws and we saw a lot of
Fighting Chess in this tournament it's
just that's what happens when you have a
lot of strong players playing against
each other you don't see someone winning
with a large margin and not only just
draws but some of these people are just
beating each other like Sam sevian I
think has won and lost a lot of games in
this tournament he won two games in a
row then I think lost two games in a row
just everybody giving it their all in
this event we sort of get the best of
both worlds in this tournament we have a
a clear a crushing Victory by um by
blauberger in the B group and then in
this in the a group we just have a brawl
for first place
yeah and uh let's take a look at this
samian game and see what we have going
so here also we're HMO 40 so Sam gets
his extra 30 minutes
and um it says zero minutes for Mishra
but uh I think this game is going I
don't think we have a result here so
it's just clean two pawns for white uh
and it's a matter if he's going to
convert it this will be very slow
conversion he'll play G3 he will move
the Knight around the Knight will go to
D5 at some point
F4 and start pushing the pawns so it
will be can be a long game but
eventually
white should be able to convert this
and in our Christopher you game a lot of
moves have happened actually I have a
lot of motions we saw this because we
did see all these chats so the final
position we saw
we did not see A4 right this is
something we're analyzing so A4
Queen B6 check
an A5 so he doesn't want to give up his
pawn and and he played this move so
quickly but this is such a big decision
right because here
you have to think about if you just go
H5 if you start pushing your pawns and
give up this point which I know I
understand this is a difficult decision
to make giving up a pawn
but uh I think you know she does have an
hour to calculate because this can
become very concrete right because if
you take here
um so our table blade says it's a draw
so G5 and F5 so maybe or actually maybe
the way he's playing is practical
because this is uh very scary
calculation right
Bishop C4 yeah I think if I
if I get my cane
over to the queen side eventually my
three pawns will be able to stop your
Bishop but you have to be very careful
um like there could be a configuration
like Bishop G4 and then Japan's G5 h4f
F4 and um then the bishop just stops all
the pawns and you might be in uh like a
like now the pawns and Bishop don't
really matter it's a Keenan Pawn ending
and of course white is winning in this
Kingdom Pawn ending because he's he's
next to the key squares yeah so
um so this is maybe a judgment called
you
spend a lot of time calculating H5 or do
you just decide I cannot lose this pawn
and play A5 because A5 is played so
checks
there's such difficult decisions because
you know sometimes you check and it
feels like a logical move but it
misplaces your piece
and queen E5 and
Queen F5 okay so he did give up his pawn
and now H5
and now the game starts all over again
so white has to try to win this all over
again
and we will see if he succeeds and um
the best thing that Christopher has
going for him besides these three past
plans is huge advantage on the clock and
eventually white will find himself under
a lot of pressure with 17 minutes and I
I think this is how he manages to win a
lot of games and save a lot of games
this is practically just playing faster
and putting his opponent under a lot of
pressure
so now we have to consider if white can
just start pushing the pawn immediately
or should he do something else and
another question is how scary it is to
how scary are this pawns so if for
example if I just play some move if you
push can I just centralize my queen and
easily stop this Pawn
something like Bishop before and just
put the pieces on the diagonal and claim
that this Pawn can no longer move
and uh black has to figure out how to
keep making progress but also if I make
something like this then I'm exposing
myself to a lot of checks so it's
possible that I might run into a
perpetual and again we have to
figure out first if these end games work
for example if take take and something
like F5 or
should block just keep the screen on the
board
and
in our other game san Savion we don't
have many developments and Taro versus
Darda we don't have a move we will get
confirmation if we have a result in this
game because this is also crucial for
our standings
and
let's go back to Christopher's game no
moves have been made and in the meantime
while we're looking at these games we
are setting up with an interview with
our winner from Group B Felix blauberger
who won the tournament in a very
dominant fashion we're having a very
congratulations on your Victory you had
such a strong performance thank you
um so we can talk about this game you
can take us through some of the key
moments did you ever feel like you were
under pressure or was it uh it was
really complicated like uh he gave the
he gave a pawn he sacrificed the pawn
somewhere in the middle gang yes uh
which I didn't expect at all what were
you expecting here just something maybe
bishop B5 uh because now rookie 3
probably doesn't work because of G4 I
thought
um this looks very scary right maybe 25
King H1
I don't know but I'm kind of
underdeveloped so it's
uh yeah I was calculating Bishop B5
Bishop D7 and some position like this
where I exchanged she plays maybe E4
Knight D4
um
take only seven and something like this
I thought
I should be fine for sure
yeah because the banana structure we
never we never see this Knight on before
so such a strong piece but uh things
became very concrete when we went Bishop
D3 yeah Bishop D3 and I think I have to
take otherwise he kind of consolidates
Rook A1 and then I'm probably worse
um so yeah I took and
I'm sorry
yeah that was first I have to go back
with the Knight
um
and queen F4 was also logical and here I
I spent a lot of time because there were
I was calculating G6 also because it
looks logical but I was kind of scared
because of some 94 jumps uh threatening
G4
um so I played the more solid I would
say Knight D4 and calculated kind of
what happened in the game I don't know
how it is objectively but oh objectively
actually it's all correct at least
according to this engine but coming into
this round uh what was your preparation
like were you because you knew if you
draw you secure the title so where
you're trying to be more solid or do you
just that I'm just going to play the
same way I've been playing yeah I think
I've been playing solid anyway at least
I hope so and I just wanted to to keep
that strategy I don't take any
unnecessary risks um and just play how I
how I have and I think it works out
pretty well
and so you played 94 Bishop went to five
so you took on D6 yeah this was all this
was all pretty concrete so I kind of had
to calculate this all before I played
Knight D4 because if it doesn't work uh
like this queen C7 then I'm probably
busted
so actually let me
so this one you spent five minutes but
it goes all the way to here and here
rookie 3 is still I think the only move
yeah that works so so everything worked
out well for you
actually instead of rookie three there
was something nice to calculate it was
Bishop D3 98 and 92 here
but here's King F2 and ah because every
other move you take yeah even there it's
kind of continued uh because Queen E7 he
has Queen B8 so that's kind of his
oh Queen G7 we've laundered the segment
many times
it's good it's good it's okay
um okay so you did not go for this
rookie three
and then all this and here also you're
spending a bit of time so were you
considering F6 maybe yeah but it looks a
bit uh weakening somehow like even then
he just goes Queen G4 and if I take then
he has some checks and
I didn't see the reason to so you took
and and then you played rookie three and
we're actually wondering if Rook D4 is a
possibility but understandably there is
some threads on the e-file but this Pawn
is also quite weak and it's possible
that he cannot hang on to this yeah did
you consider this
a bit down but I just thought I will
again like played solid and uh don't
allow any tricks but it's
for sure possible he also told me after
it again that Rook D4 he was a bit
worried about and I might be pushing
yeah Queenie it is important
but there are some tricks like Queen G5
here uh yeah but oh yeah here it doesn't
quite work out I think here you have F6
I have yeah Queen H5 G6 yeah but with
low time I was a bit uh hesitant to play
like that yeah and then what happened in
the game everything
you wanted yeah it was actually
optimistic in this end game but B4 I
think is pretty strong because if I
manage to bring my king to D6 then he's
under quite some pressure but I think B4
equalized
on the spot and all of this happened and
of course you reach move 40 and you
operator drop so
and yesterday you were playing against
Jason and that was you're playing for
the title so we were Point ahead and you
were out actually again under quite a
bit of pressure how did you feel about
that game yeah yesterday we'll see if I
can pull up this yesterday was pretty
crazy
how did you feel about yesterday's game
uh first of all he surprised me in the
opening because uh he usually went for
this love but against me I guess he
prepared something that's why I went
just 2d3 to get him out of the theory
and then we just got some normal
position but later I mean he played very
fast and very confident and at some
point it kind of escalated so when where
so the first time we saw the position
was when when he had already no first
position we saw was this one
this one
and so how did you feel around here
not so well to be honest like I was I
was low on time I at like 10 minutes
here at 40 minutes I think the queen is
completely out of place uh I think there
was also some F4 for him that was
concretely almost winning at some point
uh but somehow I survived this and I
think later I was maybe even better yeah
you reach this kind of endgame and how
did you feel about this end games
because this looked very scary for you
as well yeah I think the computer gives
some Edge for white but on the board
yeah it doesn't feel at all like that uh
that's why I also exchanged Queens which
is probably also not a great decision
but uh
it turned out to be a draw somehow in
the end so so where did you feel already
comfortable in this game that you
thought
um you're out of danger and
you're just going to go until when you
shook hands you're like okay yeah it was
finally until we shook hands I think
that was the moment where I I was
confident that it's a draw yeah this was
a very intense game and of course you
had a great Fighting Chance so it was
great for us to see that so what are the
rest of your plans are you playing any
other tournaments in the US
no it's it's not planned uh I'm mostly
playing in Europe some some leagues uh
and working as a coach working as a
second so oh it's the second two who
oh really okay so that's that must be
very
preparing for
yeah World Cup uh could be that he he
will play uh but also the Prague Masters
which he won last year uh and some some
other events too okay well we wish you
some luck
in tournaments and as a second
and congratulations again on winning
this tournament and we hope to see you
back here playing in St Louis again
thank you me too and that was the winner
of Group B
and he won the tournament with a
dominant score collecting the first
place four thousand dollars and while we
were chatting with him we got the news
that Darius Ruth won his game against
Daniel Darda which puts him in a first
place tie
uh with right now at least against
Benjamin Park and Benjamin gledora and
we're expecting some Savion to join him
and possibly Christopher your yaser
quesada depending on what happens in
this game and that game and we will get
the chance to talk to daro so I think
after Bishop H3 since we don't didn't
get any other moves
it is safe to believe that
it was a this is when the resignation
happened and we will get a chance to
talk to Daryl after this game because we
didn't get a chance to see it so
congratulations on your Victory thanks
you had a really tough game yesterday
where you probably forgot the
preparation and you ended up under a
devastating attack so how did it feel to
come into this round today well I mean
yesterday's game was of course terrible
I mean like I mean we enjoyed it I have
to say it was a nice attack I mean for
me it was terrible it was great for
brain jumping of course but I mean
yesterday what happened is like uh I I
mean I had preparation to move like 17
or 18 or something I mean Benjamin never
played it but uh I mean I had it
prepared for like grounds before and I
happen to remember everything up to a
point of course and yeah so here it was
Queen d8 yeah and now um
was supposed to be in some slight
inaccuracy maybe it's it's actually not
inaccuracy but like in terms of uh the
fact that I can play 97 right now uh
there are other moves I say Rook F2 was
interesting or D4 was interesting but
the points after in order to have after
97 Knight D6 that was one of the ideas
from what I remember so that's why F1
that's 197 I was pretty happy with my
position
uh because then if that this is 95 Tempo
on The Rook so he took on D5 takes takes
Knight C3 and I guess I haven't analyzed
it to
um
deeply enough uh because here I realize
that there's some some problems
um and I thought from the far that I
could play D4 because I never want to
play Knight B6 because now it would be
simply terrible of course I never wanted
to do that really so I tried D4 Knight
D5 uh Knight E5
F4 and yeah and basically here I saw
that I could play Bishop B6 Rook D4 King
h8 and this was the best way I could I
saw that but I wasn't sure about E4 it's
gonna hang on to this Pawn that's signal
Rook C4 if B5 can play like proxy one or
something to press press stop Knight C6
and it's an unclear position but I
didn't like being pawned down so
um engine gives like equal but again
from here point of view I wasn't really
sure so I decided to play Knight C6 and
I calculated uh I was calculating the
stuff I my calculation malfunctioned
yesterday and I saw of course 9 F6 and I
saw GF Rook H4 I saw all these moves
through gate Queen H6 F5 and here I just
thought that he has to take on H7 and
the funny thing is that even okay this
is what I calculated was this sorry
sorry not the queen my bad Rook H5 was
calculated F6 uh Queen H7 King avoid and
Rook H6 as well was my main line and I
thought the night after 95 is just a
draw because he has to repeat uh Queen
AJ King F7 he can't play Roger 96 so
that's why he has to repeat Queen Seven
King ever this was this is why I went
for it I thought like oh okay when I
decided to go for it I was like okay
it's gonna be a Droid he goes for this
unless he plays a Brilliance I'm gonna
lose very quickly
and I went down very quickly yeah so he
plays Bishop before which is actually a
very strong move did you just completely
plunder this or it's not no no I I
didn't realize it's so lost I didn't
realize my intuition my calculation like
it was a terrible game pretty much yeah
so here is just totally lost of course
like there's nothing I can do yeah so
going into today's round I was feeling
um
I mean I didn't I mean I didn't really
feel like I did uh I'm doing the
overrated by the tournament so I was
feeling pretty pretty good despite this
terrible loss I mean some games
sometimes games like this happens so I
wasn't really putting too much uh
um I don't know into it like I was just
so okay happened let's go to the next
game
and I just want to play chess I just
were playing on the three no Theory just
want to play another three uh and we'll
see what he does so basically we go up
and uh
um to to play this English Queen Seven I
remember I look in Queen D7 some time
ago and I thought it was a little bit
sketchy uh I would say I mean there are
disabilities
B6 and Bishop B7 and basically put the
bishop on this the long diagonal
commuterize my own Bishop on G2 and then
maybe playing yes this runs is 95 or
something like that so Queen D7 I just
play B6 Bishop B7 e697 stuff like that
um and the idea is that if the bishop
comes early to this B7 diagonal uh to
this Square on the diagonal
um black is supposed to be fine
um but the issue is that I can play this
move E3 and I think it's the main move
takes on C4 I just play D4 of course we
should take and now I can take with both
parts I for taking the Deep ones a bit
more human uh in order to basically play
a foreign
yeah right
the entire diagonal is basically
collapsing so maybe he could have played
like instead of I mean I saw engine
saying F6 that I wasn't considering but
the city looks kind of strange maybe I
can play more like B4 at some point or
whatever
um also has gonna develop his knife from
G right it looks better for him yeah
actually before was one suggestion yeah
yeah so such a difficult move yeah so uh
I was pretty having a position here and
I thought after E5 I mean I didn't
really calculate much to spend some time
but I didn't recognize but just felt the
right to play it because I had to open
position for my Bishops and
um what was throwing me off he played
these all these moves very quickly and
actually I was really surprised because
the first position is just very very
difficult for him it takes season I
thought just before it just opens up the
queen size right away and there's not
much you can do
just rolling the pawns and this looks
terrible also the two Bishops right yeah
yeah and actually this was interesting
when we went and played F5 because I
also the moves but after A5 he doesn't
have really a good move because if he
plays Queen of fire like in the gaming I
have Bishop before but there are also
other funny line like Queen G4 for
example forcing the queen trade
but Queen G4 doesn't work because when I
takes E5 uh Queen D1 Rook D1
um takes and takes on B7 and Bishop G5
and basically it doesn't hold his D5 aha
so he's forced to take and basically
we'll just have a next move and just you
might uh right
and I mean everything just Falls so this
is what I calculated uh but Queen F5 uh
also quick move I just playing at H4 91
doesn't really matter I guess
um just attack continues so now Bishop
F4 yeah G5 was a good try and I I
thought that it takes B6 wins I agree
for these wins but I want to keep things
simple uh I didn't want to I didn't feel
like calculating too much yeah I saw
this Knight H4 it should be winning of
course and uh but I didn't want to go
of course
yeah so I kind of missed but again I was
kind of lazy at this point I I wanted I
saw I can tell you if I was plenty good
like Queen E2 and he doesn't really have
a move if the entire attack just
continues every other bunch of
weaknesses
a492 simply uh this looks just just oh c
takes before it looks so scary for him
yeah about the entire position looks
already pretty so the first time we saw
your game it was already something like
this yeah it was a bit tricky for me
because he has somebody H2 and stuff but
I think just a free neutralizes
everything so how does this work I mean
so this would be made of course so
Bishop H3 I wasn't sure because of
Bishop takes E4
rg4 simply okay
yeah what about G4 instead of Bishop
takes E4
I was expected 9g5 right
and then to find another three it's also
I can get made
so either three yeah
we made it uh so yeah I was a bit scared
here that's why I decided to
um
I thought this is just a safer solution
and that's that's it pretty much I mean
just so your laziness today really paid
up yes
yeah I mean I just have a couple of
extra pounds I mean I'm just like
then with some
uh yeah we saw this we really like this
and then it's the most technical I guess
way to convert it yeah
just pawns and then you took this with
all of this there is one more I don't
think this is much right but listen I
mean why yeah better not to allow us if
I don't have to so Bishop S3 here
AI so the game that we have some
syrians responsible win but I think the
most interesting game is this one so
this one was a crazy game on my face I
feel like it feels like he's gonna he's
gonna hold
so how do you find so why because the
king is just very weak and there's some
counter play so just a Perpetual or how
do you hang on to this
this reminds me actually of his of Chris
uh Secrets game against uh yeah and uh
it was Game hero number two it's very
similar so like
queen of five
okay so it's just hard to hard to make
progress right yeah so this game
I mean I thought he was winning like
before he played Queen B4
so that was it yeah some key moments in
the position there's so many checks so
all of this happened yeah like in 435 I
think actually one move before I was
thinking I mean during the game I just
was walking around and I was just
thinking to myself instead of Queen B4 a
queen C8 then C6 doesn't just oh just
Queen the party probably pushed the pawn
and it's just queening
so I mean because I'm gonna escape from
Choice oh he has a lot of times yes I
was very smart sequence before Queen
series he just came over
yeah Quincy is just very difficult to
stop this one because your king will
eventually somehow get to it there must
be there can be Perpetual visible
different policy too and C7 is just
Queen d8 and that's it right I mean so
this was quite good too so Queen F6 and
unfortunate before him was King D1
because after Queen E3 it's sort of in a
zoo bank because yeah because you really
want to do this but then there's a power
one yeah
so from here he gave up the C Pawn
eventually because he just couldn't get
away
from the Palm to on the checks and then
this position and this is the last
position with uh
so black has made quite a bit of
progress so you think more likely to be
a draw I think so
so if it's a draw then at least a
four-way tie will be five-way time and
actually I know what happens if it's a
four-way time not 100 sure about what
happens if it's a five-way tie so are
you are you going to be preparing for
this tie breaks no I'm not gonna prefer
anything and you're just gonna calculate
it no no I didn't prefer I mean I
prepared a little bit last night uh
before this game today and I just
decided to play another frame number one
and just see what happens because I just
didn't want to go into any Theory
especially that like against uh Benjamin
godura I prepared 18 moves and then I
just played one over one it was it so I
just didn't want to like go into any of
that and the same thing also against ABI
Mishra that I have preparation of number
18 or something and then I play one move
and I blunder so I was like okay let's
just clear out my head and just play
normal just from number one forget about
all the prep and so on just play normal
choice this is what I want to do today
so no collaboration I mean there was
some preparation but basically not too
deep and you know in terms of more like
ideas and decisions rather than exact
lines and memorization they have
a glitter right because from pan AMS I
guess godura actually never played oh
really well I play one game in this
rapid Chess Championship on chase.com
last year and right now in this
tournament against Benjamin broke many
times of course against Amsterdam also
many times
um and the other because other
Christopher you have played against them
or else a couple of times so actually
Benjamin godura is against Benjamin
Glover play the least games
so you would expect
your prediction yeah
yeah
so this is going to be a really long day
for us watching the tyrex but we're
looking forward to it and good luck to
you you know rest well and clear your
head we're looking forward to seeing you
in the playoffs thank you
congratulations on your win today and we
only have two games left in the section
and Christopher you game which we're
expecting most likely to end in a draw
but of course still a lot of moves will
be played and this game of Sam Sabian
versus Abu Mishra where he's up to pawns
and eventually
he will be able to convert this actually
we haven't seen what has happened in
this game at all so we can take a look
and see how we got here in the first
place so some Serbian playing Ace love
with E3
so we get some slot positions B3 so it
also looks like he's avoiding any kind
of theory
and some did have a couple of tough
losses and so he was he's in a pretty
good position coming into this round
four out of eight still at 50 percent uh
actually he did win his game yesterday
if I'm not mistaken and today he's
playing very off-bit lines
would be three Bishop B2
and simply putting all his pieces in the
center room and getting blocks dark
squared Bishops so we're looking at this
a bit before uh we started this
broadcast so black has given up the
starts with Bishop so we already talked
about this from the nitzo positions that
um that gives up this bishop and now we
have a big Central tension and at some
point this tension will get resolved
because these pawns are not just going
to be facing each other forever at some
point they will be taken in One
Direction or another either the takes C5
or she takes D4 so and it's going to be
a matter of how black is going to be
able to control this bishop
and uh he played
Castle they take C4 already we see one
way it's getting resolved and queen E7
and actually Queen E7 is a bit of
inaccurate move because this move allows
the bishop and the queen to stay on the
diagonal and the Move That was supposed
to be played here by black is 94 kick
the screen away from the diagonal and
now
Queen E7 can be possibility maybe bring
the other Knight but instead Queen E7
played and the way white takes advantage
of this really nice move D5
to Simply utilizing the fact which has
happened in the game that you cannot
take back because of checkmate
and the bishop is alive and on the
longest diagonal so that's a very happy
bishop and positionally already some
pressure on black because long term this
is very annoying to deal with
as compensation there is three verses
too so maybe at some point black is able
to create some kind of a pass pawn and
some activity here yeah it feels like
every day we say the same thing her
Bishop is better than a knight and that
is uh why white is better especially in
these open positions where where nice
can be easily dominated
yeah this bishop is just on an open
diagonal and actually we saw a couple of
games where Bishop is an open diagonal
and on the longest diagonal but there is
nothing on the diagonal for example if
we had this bishop then we can claim
okay that's a nice Bishop but there is
nothing significant but this bishop is
actually aiming at the king
and there's a queen in front of it so
The Rook FDA logical move and now Knight
H4 with the ID of Knight F5
so now the threat is to play before get
this Queen off and take this Rook but
now Rook G5
Knight F5 must have also been a
possibility if Queen here how do we
defend everyone
there must be tactics right because I
don't believe you can just take my
pieces
this is this is how I play tennis I kind
of believe you can take my pieces
uh can I go here I believe four let's
say take take 24 but now Queen D5 is
possible oh no it's still 97.
all right I should have believed your
disbelief
with confidence and you're like oh they
must have calculated this I'm just not
gonna take it when you say do something
with confidence people just believe you
it's fair
uh Knight of five but uh things start to
hang so instead he played Rook G5 with
the threat of Knight F5 and G6 this is
not a movie you're thrilled to play
because
no you just cannot move your Knights no
we talked about how good that Bishop was
before but the bishop on this diagonal
uh usually black has a bishop on G7 when
they play G6 that guards this diagonal
the reverse is uh is never fun to deal
with and this
Rook D5 so he provokes G6 and goes back
and then just goes back doesn't want to
deal with this anymore but it just feels
like why not something like this here
and what do we do
Maybe
okay I want to move back as well like
Knight G3 to go 94 maybe well before
it's coming right or it's not coming I
mean before can I just take and go like
crazy yeah
and now actually Rook D5 it's pretty
annoying because I'm also thinning right
yeah this is pretty tough Rook D1 also
just get on every piece on the file
like after Rook D5
oh
yeah
yeah this is pretty difficult but
instead he went Rook D5 and then he went
back so it just feels a bit like a
concession why not
ah before is a threat
wait a minute ah
yeah now Queen D4 is impossible because
Queen E5 comes and there's no more
annoying Knight E7 check
so I managed I managed I kind of wanted
to take bugs like
I could use pen work so just lose
everything here wow this is quite
unfortunate so that's why he slides back
but I think this is a bit of a
concession before
so I will decides to give up his ABI it
decides to give up his Pawn
so Rook D1 okay
still a lot of problems I
think
um D4 you still cannot take because this
is just horrible I mean you can't play
F6 but again you just cannot move your
pieces like F3 will come before will
come and
um I mean okay F3 Queen F6 already looks
really bad
so instead The Rook just leaves the file
but now white also has the file
and this is just um
no you I have the pawn on the
compensation right okay you got F6 you
kind of shut down this diagonal a bit
but also created a weakness now Rook D6
is coming we're dominating the file and
also this is hanging
and I think you didn't find a way of
dealing with Rook D6 so he went here but
this gives up another Pawn
yeah I mean black white was threatening
to win a piece there so I don't think he
could have done anything uh anything but
Queen B6 right like Rick C5 is just a
huge threat and
yeah I just came over his only other
option was something like this right but
yeah it was just a piece right I don't
know it doesn't look very impressive
so this happened so we will see how we
ended up in the end game even here this
bishop is so dominant yeah so some
people might like bail and play Bishop
C3 here because you're like oh the
night's scary on C3 but Sam Sabian an
experienced Grandmaster does not I mean
also this is pretty good but it doesn't
want to give up the bishop which is a
monster on F6 is this scary this chicks
maybe right because check maybe I go
here so if you take maybe I start to get
some compensation here
some unnecessary things although even
this looks really good like in E3 you
take on G2 but so what king of Threes oh
wait I tell mating one nice I was
thinking King G3 rooked you too but this
is yeah
but okay so no reason to align if this
so that's why it goes rookie one stops
stops to check and this is actually a
good technique right because computer
plays with D6 but as a human you also
want to minimize risk and minimize can
replace so you don't allow any of this
so it goes for this Pawn of course
cannot take this hangs
and now he's up three pawns So
eventually he did lose one of the Pawns
over two not a lot of the Rooks to come
in
he gave up this Pawn as it's impossible
to defend it but now this rule comes in
but he is simplified to rook and Knight
versus Rook at night but you have an
extra extra two pawns on F3 and E4 just
a pretty easy end game to convert I have
to say so let's see how the conversion
is going to take place 91
choose the night away that goes back out
of four
and here you can kind of just Shuffle
around until you stumble upon some some
wind
yeah I think many
there are many paths
um he took only four because
um probably just simply cannot find a
move
so he decides to go for this actually we
did not see this right King F7
I would have seen this kind of night
rook and pawns versus rook and ponds in
this tournament several times but I
think this is the best version we've
seen because it's just a pure night yeah
I think in the other end games black had
some extra pawns and also like white
skin was way over on the other side of
the board which obviously gives uh
greater chances to the defending side
that when all your pieces are defended
and you're up at night typically these
end games I mean they can be tough to
convert in the sense of like move time
like it might take you a long time but
they shouldn't be they shouldn't be too
bad too
um to convert in the end yeah I think
it's just maybe time consuming so where
did this night oh King g794 so next he's
going to play G5 put a knight here
maybe even come and check with you
so this is just if Mishra decides to
keep playing so this is just going to
take some moves uh otherwise this is
just going to be a pretty smooth victory
for Sam there's some break I take it
back immediately yeah there's some
breaking news in the U game apparently
you has uh has made some some mistakes
and uh and now Yasser quesada Perez has
winning chances again oh what happened
see this is what happens when we make
predictions actually I'm blaming this on
Darrow because yeah we learned our we
learned from our mistakes because he
came here and he was like yeah this is
most likely will be a drum so this
happened
green one two G3 Queen C6 all of this
very logical
is a mistake which is very surprising
because
actually if you take there's also you
should stay because you cannot Pi Square
Bishop cannot cover there would be no
playoffs Christopher would win the
tournament
that would make it a very short day for
us but not what we're going to see
instead Queen A5 and Bishop D5 so
putting the pieces on the long diagonal
so Queen went to F2 now c4 now the pawn
is moving
and if H2 I think the claim is that you
do not have a threat but I also cannot
go C5 because this is hanging also it
cannot go here right because checks
yeah so what do we play here I so my
first instinct which probably isn't very
good would be to play something like
Queen E4 just to like
fully secure the H1 Square be as like
safe as possible but I think yeah maybe
maybe safety isn't the way that you win
this end game
I actually have no idea how I would
proceed here with white but probably I'd
play Queen E4 and just not win but
that's
that's why I'm here and not there so
let's try to break down this end game so
let's try to understand it so there's
key things going on right so first you
have to make sure this Pawn doesn't
Queen
so so far this bishop is covering this
uh square and this diagonal and so I
think you always have to make sure that
you're either attacking this Pawn so
this queen cannot just move and you know
threaten to Quinn or you're able to
quickly put the queen on the same
diagonal as the bishop so the pawn
doesn't move at the same time there's
this Pawn
but because the king is so exposed there
is also the chance or for black to make
a drug with a Perpetual so for white
white has
white has to somehow push their Pawn at
the while at the same time not allowing
black to give a perpetual and not
allowing to Queen this Pawn so in this
position from the way I see it is the
light Square Bishop is covering the H1
Square which is a light Square which is
very good for us
and the perpetuals are going to happen
on the torque squares because I have a
light Square Bishop right so you cannot
really check me on the light squares it
doesn't make that much sense so the
Perpetual is going to happen on the dark
squares so ideally what I want to do is
what I have right now right my Bishop on
the long diagonal covering H1 and the
queen of covering the dark squares so I
think we have to keep these things in
mind when we're trying to make progress
here what do you think so now tell me
now that I told you I love this what do
you think of the move that he played
played in the game because it's very
interesting to me it was not this move
was not on my radar at all Bishop H1 uh
I I suppose
um because what you what you said the
bishop is is physically blocking the
pawn from ever making any progress and
since perpetuals are going to happen on
the dark squares uh potentially the
point of this move
um is we can meet later Queen checks
with a lateral Queen defenses so like
Queen B6 maybe queen queen B5 or we move
Arcane and then eventually play the move
Queen B52 to sort of sort of defend like
for example if some kind of a trade
happens we're very happy right because
our punches quaint and our Bishop is
just here
Bishop H1 so so I think he will what
he's trying to do is instead of having
bishop and queen and Bishop in front of
the queen stopping the pawn he wants to
reverse it he wants to put a bishop here
and Queen on one of the
squares so the queen defends the bishop
so the queen is mobile
and um
then run with the King and hide so do I
have a check oh I don't have a check
here no I do have a check here so where
do I go in C3 and now no checks
so afraid to make moves here
um I mean no checks temporary so let's
okay so you go where it could be five
right it's a nice Central Square but
actually let me make a move that doesn't
thread anything just so we can make
moves and try to understand what's going
on so we're not trying to find the
objectively best moves or anything We're
just trying to break down this position
and understand what the plan is so if I
start checking you
if I check you and if I check you
I just want to understand what I was
about to go Queen A5 I was just trying
trying to understand where is this King
going to hide
maybe we can pretend to take the
kingside pawns even like King D5 and if
you check me again I'll go to E5 well
well if you take me from here so we have
to remember right we can always and then
if you keep checking me
I was thinking you would start with
Queen A8 because yeah Queen A5 C5 seems
like we're helping white out a lot
where do you want to go here or here uh
D6 feels safer and then E7 yeah so if I
check you you might actually get away
with this right so if here and then you
go to f8 and then if I just want to take
your Pawn Yeah Yeah now uh so now
actually you might be getting mated and
also Queen trade
are going to be so I think 27 might just
be wind right yeah and then you have
this cross check
it has to be made yeah yeah it's Keen of
six is just force Checkmate because
teenage six
um no a queen oh wait wait actually I
said that and then I understand why you
oh yeah yeah so here Bishop F3 I think
I'm running
but I don't I don't see him oh wait
check oh bishop g2's checkmate oh damn
nice that's that's that's very rare you
get to see uh Queen and queen and Bishop
versus queen bee be winning but concrete
variations
yeah very nice so no that's a good idea
actually running and taking that F7 Pawn
so we do actually have a lot of moves in
the game so let's see what this moves
for
so
wait Our Queen G1 was played Queen D5 so
Queen we played Queen E4 and the reason
we I wanted to play Queen E4 is because
Queen D5 turns the pawn so this becomes
more concrete and I just wanted to kind
of explore the position because I have
the luxury of doing that yeah and you
know we explore that position we
understand the ideas for them it's very
concrete right they have to calculate so
Queen D5 immediately threatens have
someone with a check so block doesn't
have
um all the time in the world so check
comes back checks and he goes D3 so
there is a few ways for me to run right
so
what did I do
I went too far back so can I escape this
way no right Queen A6
yeah maybe now uh Queen B5 is more
possible if you go Queen G1 I can block
I go yeah to B7 and then uh then my king
goes and runs to E7 again I'm always
afraid of the skewers but I keep
forgetting my coin is defended yeah
something like this actually might be
hugely problematic right because my king
is now going towards the queen side and
your Pawn is hanging so now you have to
keep checking me and the check is
actually starting to help me because
you're just pushing me towards the king
yeah once again to reiterate um the
queen traits are never acceptable for
black so like King C5 Queen B7 Bishop B7
you might think that the pollen H2 is
really strong for uh for black but the
issue is that we're just going to Queen
our Pawn before you will make any
additional progress on the king side
yeah are upon the fact that our parties
on C4 is actually a huge difference
because we're two moves closer to
queening so that actually helps white
quite a bit so I was thinking the king
can go either to E5 to A4 sorry uh to
the queen side or the way he's doing it
is going towards the center I wonder see
this is the problem because
instinctively you want to keep checking
right but I wonder if this is helping
black because now my king can start
moving towards yeah somewhere I think as
soon as white skin attacks the F Pawn
black is going to be in a lot of trouble
I don't think you should let that happen
but also I don't know how you prevent it
so maybe white is just flat out winning
at this point so if you go some if you
keep check if you check me from here I
think I go this way right if you keep
checking me again and this is even worse
because now two pieces are attacking so
here and then here
yeah at some point you know you can
check me again but then F7 disappears
and once F7 disappears The End Game
becomes uh dare I say trivial
yeah because uh any kind of Trades
any kind of coin trades we don't even
have to think about it right because
it's just two ponds and this Pond if it
ever reaches to G2 I will just take it
so it'll just take you too long and you
also have an exposed Kink so with check
you might lose the we checks you might
lose the H2 Pawn so I don't think you
can afford to lose F7 to have a fighting
chance after King D4 the time situation
is 10 minutes to 25 minutes or actually
I haven't seen Christopher to only have
25 minutes
yeah so and uh they have been playing
since 11 o'clock so they have been
playing for four and a half hours
already this has been a very long game
so you know this is a very difficult
battle for the players fighting for a
chance to win the tournament uh so
there's a lot on the line for them
they're playing for a price fund of 22
000 dollars so and the title of course
so there is you know a lot to fight for
and it is the last round so in the last
round you know you can just give your
roll because you're done unless you go
into playoffs yeah so of course they are
going to do their best to find every
possible resource and it looks like
tables actually have really turned and
maybe white will be winning this game
yeah just a real back and forth battle
between these two and
um I'm sure that nerves are playing a
big deal as well both players know what
they're fighting for and that's why it's
easy for us to say oh well they may make
some mistakes because we we see
everything uh with the you know we can
make moves and take them back but uh
these guys have been playing for a long
time and these end games are never easy
for either side no they're not because
it's so hard to understand the
difference between one move another move
this check or that check so this is a
very tricky position and a very tense
game and let's pick the other game of
some Savion has made huge progress this
Pawn is going to fall very quickly the
Knight will go to G3 yeah it's captured
what's unfortunate for black is that in
these end games
um even if white were to trade Rooks
normally you would have a chance because
it's an H Pawn even against a piece but
a knight is not a bishop he will always
be able to control the h8 square so um
the only time when it's interesting is
when your own cane is actually trapped
on h8 and those those end games are uh
just always always winning unless your
king is trapped and then it's 50 50.
I wanted to do something so I want to go
Knight F6 oh wait I don't want to do
that because Rook F5 or oh but King G6
you can play and yeah here I take uh so
my whole idea is you know if you take
but maybe I can be a little clever Can I
Be Clever if I check you I think if you
go here this is already not a win yeah
perpetual and Rick King H7
oh yeah I was even thinking teenage
seven Rook G7 like you pick up the Rook
if not stalemate oh this is even more
annoying yeah yeah yeah this is very
nice
and here you don't keep going no no no
no I will take your rug and then and
then black will be the one playing for
the one so that's why he didn't go
Knight F6 Sam is not here for any kind
of Misadventures so Rook C1 Knight H5
but this is nothing because you check me
I go back you check me again I go here
yeah
uh I don't think again the best chance
you might possibly have if he somehow
tries to stalemate himself but I don't
really see it happening so again black
is playing because
doesn't really have a reason not to at
this point we've come this far but I
expect this game will be over soon and
some savian after suffering a few losses
making a big comeback by winning this
Muslim game it's a really clutch clutch
victory
yeah Sam's a very exciting player he
wins a lot uh and well he loses
sometimes but you know he wins a lot of
games which is why he's probably gonna
make it to the playoffs
so this game we expect to end soon so
this move was played and now actually I
have Knight F6 because if you check me I
will take a look and if you don't trick
me I will check with you yeah you still
have Rook C7 here but here I can just
check and then take
unstill made in your opponent wait oh he
went Rook F7 oh so he just wants to do
everything with forces I know what he's
going to do he's going to do this he's
going to do this if you go here I will
to this oh man I I first yeah but he
went the other way 906 and then pushes
the king away and after I mean okay he
can do whatever he wants here at this
point yeah yeah just completely wrong 57
oh so this happened
then H5 is the easiest probably
I want it to be fancy but of course this
is ridiculous because the Palm hangs
yeah H5 and everyone's defendant and
this game
server going to C1
H6
will go anywhere it wants so the only
chance black would have would be if you
played something like K H7 and then like
Pat like both players need to cooperate
for this to happen it's like Teenage
eight then Rook H2 then H7 and then we
trade Rook somehow in your kingzone f8
but oh well so many things need to
happen and then you'd be winning with
white if your Knight's on the opposite
color of your king so this is this is an
important endgame to know it won't
happen at all in this game but if you
get your king trapped in the corner like
this though with a knight and an H Pawn
if the Knight is on the same color as
you're uh the same color as your
opponent's cane it's a draw and if it's
the opposite color you always win
fortunate for black the king is all the
way on the other side of the port let's
see the position we have here some is
playing very careful you will push the
spawn he'll put something on H5 and
promote this Pawn so this game will be
ending any minute now
and we have one game going in group a
and we heard news that in group b Victor
mihalovski won his game so a very
comfortable win of course for uh Felix
and we do see a result yeah resignation
by abhimanyu Mishra which is not
surprising at all yeah great Victory by
Savion very clutch game
and let's see what do we have in this
position so actually I don't have too
many mobs right because we left off
I'm getting a bit confused so here okay
with all of this we saw this we saw this
checks
King E5 Queen G5 I wouldn't see this so
this is the live position we have King
Z6 only logical move but the queen d8
how does this King escape this Chucks
all right at some point we will go
Queen V7 right yeah
and then you check and once again all
the coin trades are trivially winning
for for white so you must play Queen D6
and then um probably King B5 here it
seems good enough because whatever check
you play I'll meet with C5 and I've made
I've made progress in the position I
actually don't really have many checks
right Queen E5 is only check
C5 oh wow this route has dropped
everything why is that the case
[Music]
wow these end games are so tricky so oh
I see it's because like you don't have
this move because
um C5 is not a trade
wow
okay so don't do that don't play like me
play better okay so Queen C6 is what
we're calculating Quincy plate but you
have to go to B6 right because you came
from D6 so this is the most logical
so only check left Queen B7 here I was
thinking oh can I pluck and I realized
we can just get a queen I'm not actually
blocking you
and but he actually can be five Queen E5
we can go Queen D5 again maybe or is
that no there's that no good can you say
it again or so so uh Queen E5 check uh
King B5 instead of 25 or sorry
a queen D6 King B5 Queen E5 so instead
of my horrible C5 move maybe we could we
could try the move Queen to D5 and then
Queen V8 and then we um we start our run
again like can't see
5 to D6 and
um I actually
we have to understand what we're running
to write
so okay King B5 played here
so I'm expecting this move can I go
all right okay but now I don't have a
way to vlog
so where is what's the point after Queen
B8
so
so what's the plan after Queen be it
Queen B7 perhaps yeah Queen B7 but this
is a transposition to this like C5
doesn't work here right
so yeah but if the 5 doesn't work so
first of all he has to realize that C5
doesn't work
which of course easier for us to
understand
before Queen beard was played and now we
have to figure out what is White's plan
here where is the skin going to hide
because if I go here you check so now I
cannot block because this hangs
can I go I don't have a move I have to
go back it doesn't make sense yeah maybe
we can try to run that way with the
queen on B7 so like if after Queen ba
check we go Queen B7 like what you
wanted but then um after Queen E5 check
we go to B6 so this is the game actually
we go to B6
um oh now your C point is hanging again
apparently ah yeah Queen A7 you have
Queen A2 oh this is unfortunate yeah oh
no but yeah
ah no Queen D4 Queen this is actually a
double attack okay so we have to be
careful here
so he played Queen B7 this is the game
so now Queen E5 check
what uh what to do so C5 is not a good
move
so the King has to go somewhere
to King B6 uh
yeah so where can I go to get away from
this never-ending stream of checks maybe
you can C6
my idea was if you go to E6 I can go to
C5 and I thought this was an improvement
for me because now I can
um sort of shuffle my pieces towards the
king side
five again
oh it's it's a difficult It's Tricky
yeah
Queen and queen end games are not not
the end games humans are well known for
playing well no because they're so so
tricky and you know but this is
difficult for Christopher too because
Queen E5 you know we're saying oh
Queenie fives C5 with a blunder but like
psychologically to play a check to allow
his opponent's Pawn to move
and it's a temple move right because if
someone is having is hanging
psychologically this is such a difficult
move to play unless you're sure that
your checks are good or this is not
going to just cost you the game it's
again this part this evaluation that we
have is just such a big hint for us but
over the board for you to make this
decision I think it's very difficult
because how do you just allow your
opponent's Pawn to push how do you
encourage your opponent's function yeah
I mean there's a reason why initially I
was like oh yeah I just play C5 here and
I win but
it's uh what's lucky for Christopher is
because he's up on time in every game he
plays he will have time to make this
decision so I think that's why he's
thinking right now he knows that if he
if he plays the wrong check like for
instance if you play Queen E8 check
maybe you'll end up too passive and uh
White can play something like
Keen uh King A6 or Kane it's hard to
finish the sentence right yeah I was
also like I was like yeah yeah how do I
finish the sentence
yeah this is extremely tricky he won 28
so he didn't go Queen E5 so again easy
very easy to say when you have a
computer what's right what's not as a
human it's so hard to encourage your
opponent to play the move they want to
play with a tempo
uh so but here let's try so if I go King
B6 let's say you go Queen E3 now C5 what
is the difference now I'm hiding right
now you don't have a very so now you
actually
you do this do I want to go C6 now I've
disconnected my Bishop on the queen so
now I'm very nervous
so I don't want to do this I want to
play I want to put my queen on D5 ideal
and then go C6 so wait sorry but after
C6 I just want to understand because I I
there must be a concrete reason right
like if if I could just play C6 then C7
the game is over so you probably have
Perpetual immediately here somehow yeah
I think you're a queen and uh your Pawn
just uh stops your queen king from
escaping so where you want to go so
first of all you can never allow me any
kind of check from the back rank right
so where do you want to go so C7 I gotta
go here and then King b80 and then you
give the the queen d8 A5 and then Queen
B6
Queen A5
yeah this is this is a useful pattern to
know we can even potentially Queen B4
maybe even if we can zigzag to the back
rank then black has winning chances
given is this
oh this is a mistake but how do I make a
draw here look uh can we go back
actually I wanted to try Queen B4
instead of Queen B5 with black oh yeah
yeah of course you go on the dart score
it's very I mean we had a whole uh oh no
but queen queen yeah
and if Queen here and G or queen T4 also
yeah
I'm staying on the dark squares always
stay on the dark scripts yeah of course
because all your pieces are in the light
squares right I'm not going to ever give
you Perpetual on the light squares yeah
so this made sense we need three
king of seven queen of two but here also
like if you play here
so you go this way right and then you
come back yeah and then I cannot uh
something like this I think even Queen
D2 might be possible because now I check
on tape right like if I start getting
adventurous now yeah I do think that
White's probably has enough to make a
draw because like you have to play Queen
F1 here right like Queen H1 would fail
to Queen G8 check and queen G6 would be
this would be a really unfortunate way
to lose
but Queen F1 we have to play and then we
can start giving checks
Keen
cleaning my palm and I are to one of us
to be careful here yeah yeah for sure so
this will this will end in some kind of
I think Queen H3 is Perpetual luckily
for white I think otherwise now you have
the same pattern
pattern yeah so we made it
so we're more we're on this is a Titanic
battle we're almost 702 and this game is
going to go on for many more moves
so in the game we have Queen C6 right we
were analyzing King V6
so what if we go oops
all right if you're checking from here I
go to A6
oh yeah this is a nice pattern because
the queen has no the queen on C6 guards
every relevant check and uh
and now it's black to play and improving
moves for black are very difficult to
come up with
so you have to you cannot push pawns
because now we trade queens and pushing
this Pawn is also very scary for me
because
you're exposing your kings to a lot of
moves and what I like about this C5 move
I'm also controlling Queen D6 check so
now my king is very safe and now I can
actually maybe even play something like
Queen D7 and start moving this Pawn so
this looks like huge progress so in the
game Queen yeah let me
finally learning how to use this so in
the game Queen 132
not checking and now King B6 and the
idea is if you check me I think it's the
same idea right Queen E7
I go Kings no King City of Queen hates
I can't play this you can get
discriminated I go here
yeah once again you have oh there's
Queen B2 check actually
um wait what did I miss uh so Kim B7
there's Queen B2 check right but oh now
Queen B6 and finally there are no more
checks but now you can attack my Bishop
again
again so I go here and then you have to
go back
yeah
so let me see what happened so he won
team B6 check and he went to A6
so if I check
you go to B7 and if I check you go to C8
check
oh this is a funny way your king
dominates the queen no more jokes for a
move no more checks at least
actually you don't even have a move that
threatens a check right or yeah if you
if you go away you also have to be
careful like King E7 will come because
once again if the F Pawn disappears then
White's task becomes a lot easier
something like this yeah I'd I'd be a
big fan of of playing this way with
white
yeah this was yeah because then any kind
of blog can also be a check so you
cannot really check me on the seventh
Rank and allow me to block on the seven
because there'll be with a check so
Queen B two King went to H6 and
I said Christopher plate I cannot see
what he played it's Queen A3
King B7 will be quick uh so this is
actually very good for Yasser because
it's getting a lot of moves in and he
needs the time because at some point I
think he will need to sit down and
calculate
uh what's going to happen and this is
such a clutch round because both Darrow
and some savian
clutch victories tank for first and yasu
if he wins this game if he converts this
then you know with two wins in a row he
wasn't always leading or co-leading the
tournament but with two lead two wins in
a row in the last two rounds and he will
find himself in a tie for first place
yeah it's it's actually amazing that
plus one is going to be good enough to
to win this tournament I don't think
this has ever happened before and um I
mean it couldn't be any more contested
than that right like half the tournament
could end up being uh being in the tie
breaks no this is uh this is a very
strong tournament and as you mentioned
before we didn't get here with a lot of
drafts we actually got here with a lot
of decisive results because I don't
think we've had a round where there were
all draws I don't remember this
happening
and this game like last round we had a
decisive results this round will have
possibility decisive results and this is
what we like to see we like to see
Fighting Chess even in the drum game we
had a lot of Fighting Chess so this has
been a really exciting tournament yeah
like Christopher Christopher you only
has a chance to qualify to the tie
breaks this round because he held that
like incredible end game against Savion
like at so many points in time I might
have just resigned with uh with white
but he kept fighting and now his
fighting might pay off I mean it's not
clear if Yasser will be able to to
convert this end game yet yeah yesterday
that game right when he was down two
pons and he found his is a really nice
Fortress to draw the game I was under
the impression that Sam won yesterday
but now you're right he drew that game
against Christopher but still a nice
recovery for sun too because at some
point he started with plus one and then
he lost two games in a row and here is
now he's going to recover so he won a
game he drew and now he is he won again
today so a really nice finish for him
and for quesada perezi also yesterday he
had a really dominant win against
yakuboyev and today he is also getting
looks like getting closer to Victory
King C8 or who's fighting for victory
and now black has to find a move because
if you don't go Queen f8 which I think
he did
well we're really just getting every
move
oh F5 he plays yeah I I don't like this
move I think when this
check anymore there is we can try but
this is too slow right yeah
you're moving two pounds and yeah the
issue is that even if we weren't fast
enough I think this end game is winning
by a lot of tempos because
um uh the problem
oh actually no never mind your threat is
to go F2 not G3 right F2 and then F1 if
you go G3 then I would take your Pawn
Yeah it's just because I have a bishop
if I had a knight then you know Knights
are a bit awkward especially on the edge
of the world but the bishop on covering
the diagonal F5 I think f526 I don't see
a move where does the queen go if the
queen goes somewhere else you don't have
any more checks now I just push my Pawn
right you can always meet the a check
with a cross with a cross pin or cross
check so Queen G7 Queen E7 is easy
enough and I mean even H2 is hanging
with Jack and oh yeah yeah everything is
just going to oh yeah I mean this is the
more human way of playing of course you
pick up the pawn and then with checks
you come back you don't even calculate
anymore it's just a it's just a bishop
here now we're cruising actually I don't
know which way you do because yeah this
is pretty dominant because the spot is
actually yours
yeah I mean I me personally I'd probably
take vh2 Pawn just because I'm a nervous
person and I never want I never want any
chance for black to win the game but
that that said I think every there are
many yeah I mean F5 I think it's maybe
Nerfs or maybe you can just realize he
doesn't have any moves I mean this is
Queen on f8 is not where you want your
queen to be you need your queen to be
checking so a queen D6 played and I
think this is already
um
looking very looking very close to one
zero it's just doesn't have any moves
here because okay Queen H6 only other
move right
so if I go C5
what can you do possibly so the only
thing you have going for you is my
Bishop is lose but at the same time if
your queen goes somewhere then H5 HTTP
tanks with a check so for example if you
play Queen C1 I take I don't even think
about it right I just take it yeah yeah
and then I could uh what is it yeah I
guess if I were to if I did this and I
put a bishop on this oh actually yeah I
didn't mean to do that but I defined my
fantastic list you cannot take and now
I'm just shielding my king my king is
shielded and this is just game over yeah
um if I were to be forced to try to
defend this position I think that Queen
H6 is probably the best attempt and then
when you play some of like C5 I'll play
something like Queen H4
and then like Queen but it's so slow H4
you're running and oh Queen E7 also yeah
but even if I go here
okay let's try this let's see no
actually instead of Queen H4 I should
play Queen H3 so that F4 comes with
check
uh you know you know what I mean like in
the previous position you want to play
what instead of Queen H4 Queen H3 and
now C6 I can play F4 with check and then
Queen F1 and at least I'm pretending to
fight
I don't think so my point is if you go
here then I block and let's say you try
to push
and I actually hear if I play something
like this this is an F2 and it's not
easy anymore this
I'm the one who's playing
for a Perpetual right yeah but of course
that's not
something we expect to see
so instead here what can I do probably
with checks I should be able to pick up
this Pawn right yeah yeah just a
concretely so you have to go up I will
check and take oh I saw E3 so there oh
three also but if I go here if I if you
go here actually now you cannot push
your Pawn because it will be made so now
I push because if you go here this will
be that's a nice it's it's a it's like
at a 90 degree angle of the normal one
oh yeah yeah
we were showing the same Dara's game
yesterday
and Checkmate so we cannot really expose
our King and this is something we
mentioned earlier if this pawns move
it's that easy to move this f-pawn
because opens the diagonal so Queen H6
was played yeah I think it is the best
try if not Queen H6 you probably resign
yeah you don't have too many legal moves
right and process elimination that's our
specialty everything loses we make the
one move so you don't want to put a
queen on AJ this is the pricing here
you're hanging the pump Queen H6 defense
the pond so you just play it you know
you don't think about what's going to
happen so I think C5 was explained and
queen H3 oh they're following our line
so practical chances C6 is possible what
else is possible let's see what else you
can think some checks
applying to these checks I don't like
them I'm just trying them out yeah he
push this on as a professional
of course yes sir quesada Perez very
strong very strong technique
and no so yeah
at fourth place so he's just playing his
practical chance because he can spend
13 minutes thinking about this position
and leave himself 30 seconds but he's
not going to come up with anything so he
just plays his practical chance I wonder
if Keen
um so of course but the players do have
time here so 10 minutes is quite a lot
of time for this sort of position
um the reason why you don't play King is
because I just noticed that Queen C8
would be a check that you need to
calculate
um
oh he's still Queen dear Queen also for
a second you know I'm scared that this
is hanging but yeah Bishop on H1 is
deceptive yeah this is so funny right
this is the best piece you have here
because it just defends this Pawn
forever
so and for his thinking this is a good
time to think you know collect your
nerves
um for a lot of players you know they
get a winning position and then they get
flustered and I think when you have a
winning position
it's best to spend the extra time double
check everything sometimes when I have
like this kind of winning position I
will check my opponents every single
legal move to make sure it doesn't work
and you know it sounds like a waste of
time but it's better than having to
start doing the work all over again
right yes so it's fun you know you think
about where you go it's the professional
approach
because
having to have this moment you know this
emotional moments in chance are so
difficult when you go from it doesn't
matter which way it goes I think it's
still a lot to handle it's almost like
traumatic even if you go from bad
position to good position it's just such
a rush of emotions
and I think can be very difficult to
handle that's why Grandmasters are very
good at this right they make a mistake
and immediately they offer a draw
because they know this is their chance
because if they give you a little time
to think they make a little more moves
you'll be like oh things have changed
but they immediately offer you a dress
so you're just like oh okay
the only time a Grandmasters have
offered me a draw were in positions
where it would be completely
unreasonable for me to accept
trigger cups no so uh I I have I also
have not won every game where I declined
so he won 26
you said King moved also a reasonable
move
Queen E6 plate
uh who told us a Grandmaster told me
this that you know uh like knowing when
to offer a draws
it's art art form yeah correct moment to
offer your opponent to draw yeah I
remember Dimitri gordievsky offered me a
draw when I had like four pieces and
like three pawns for a queen and I I
could not accept unfortunately that's so
much right so yeah that's the key now
you have to offer at the right moment
yeah when you see the tide is turning
and yeah it's not quite hasn't quite
turned you just to sense it at the right
time
23 so are we going to E8 or are we going
to eat seven so E8 I was thinking Queen
B5 but I think can get seven
he really wants to trade Queens
and now the queen will go somewhere
unclear where
does the queen go
of course again you cannot trade now you
can check again yeah but King
EA I think is this point yeah
King E8 and if you go Queen C Queen C8
then this queen d8 idea comes up
and um wherever you check me I will
cross check you well okay you only have
one check so Queen E6 Queen E7
oh then if you move I just got C7 right
and again he cannot check me out this is
nice but I thought I have another check
Queen H3 if you go kingy can I check
from here or you got five seven again
yeah I think
go into F7 is clever
sorry and then if you try to
this feels like meat but I don't see it
quite uh do you have oh so after Queen
F3 you have Queen C4 check
so oh also Queen G7 I missed maybe we
play Queen D7 here so wherever you go I
check you that's funny already checked
me here and I made it yeah with this
bishop G2 idea at the end
I'm threatening mate
yeah so if Queen Steve but also Queen C4
we will Checkmate you with the same
patterns that I have learned Queen G7
and this queen G6 Queen G5 and Bishop G2
mate which I I still can't believe like
exists and it's only because you have a
Pawn on H2 yeah
uh he won't think the eight
but now check again
and probably so we're getting a lot of
moves very quickly Queen H4 plate
yeah I'm not sure where his next check
is going to come from yeah this idea of
putting a king on episode one oh you
want to see it
oh yeah because of Queen H3 then Queen
D7 is very simple
again
um this human approach right you just
don't want to give fewer opponent
chances for us making uh 10 wolves and
then oh yeah of course and having the
evaluation tell us if it's right very
helpful but for him he's completely on
his own
and his idea is not to give his opponent
any moves so C7 is coming there's no way
to stop C7
I don't know if F3 is anything or I can
simply actually I can just take this way
right you don't have checks so this
didn't help us
so what other moves are there in the
position he's probably gonna try F3 I
saw him reach for something and I can't
I'm I don't know here he reached first
okay Queen went back but I cannot over
oh he went
the idea if C7 you check me you cannot
check me from here because if I block
you don't have Queen F5 yeah Queen D7
you can also just move your cane out
right like instead of blocking on the on
d8 if I go C7 and you go Queen f8 I
think I can go to D7 here as well
because
uh you can only check me on G7 and how
do we escape this uh King D6
and then after Queen E6 okay Queen f8
can't see so uh King C6 Queen A8 King D7
this bishop is a hero yeah yeah the
bishop on H1 is the best piece in that
position
Queen on D5 very nicely centralized
Bishop on H1 very deceptive
so wait we have oh we do have this did
we go Queenie no no he went Queen h8 We
want Queen f8 so what is the difference
oh he wants to check on B2 so if we go
but uh can I zigzag to E7
so if Queen G7 can I go here
oh no
so the answer to the question is no I
cannot go there I think I think you can
though like Queen G7 King d a yeah and
then check oh but Queen f8 again huh
yeah so maybe I need uh but uh you had a
pattern right what's this your pattern
yeah yeah this was this was my pattern
he needs to
yes seven and a half minutes a little
over seven minutes
um I wonder if King B7 is also winning
yeah I also don't really believe in
Black's defense here because after King
A8 I think oh hey yeah King A8 you check
me on the a file I go to B8 and then you
check me on the B file I have Queen B7
and uh where if you check me on f8 I
have C8 with check
if you go Queen D6 I'll go King A8 and
then Queen A3 Queen A7 and again yeah
hero and H1 and pre-move um yeah
okay so seems like a lot of ways to win
this position
and uh matter of a little more a little
bit of accuracy
so let's see which one he's going to go
it just has to control his nerves but
he's a very experienced player I expect
him to stay calm Under Pressure he went
to B7
yeah I think once you see this sequence
this becomes the simpler of the two to
play because you just block with all
your pieces and then CA comes and
okay Whitehead mini roads but also this
seems like very forcing and probably the
game just is over which one do you think
can I also put this fire by the way
because if wait this is where we came
from
yeah this also looks very nice
okay let's see which way he will go
so he has I think he would say A7 so
none of the about anything okay
but I think he will end up doing what
what I wanted I think with King B and
queen B7
so you think here he will go here yeah
and then after
um so there's no Queen in shape because
c8s and if you go
um Queen B2 I think he's gonna block
with his Queen on B7 and now there's a
discovery with the c Pawn you must try
to play with domination Queen E5 but
after King A8 luckily for me there's
this bishop on H1 which guards the
diagonal and after
yeah oh my God I missed that idea oh
that's that's irritating no but um
wait oh that disrupts everything
oh you need to stay wait a minute
so what did we say here oh maybe I just
start with so Queenie five I go Queen A7
first
yeah Queen A7 first thinking thinking
oh this makes me a little nervous plate
let's see where he's gonna go I think to
me King C6 was a bit more natural
I don't love putting my king on this
side unless you have something
calculated very precisely
and the question is where does he go can
can I go to these suits is this silly
well it's probably bad news for for him
but he went to he went to be it like me
so here yeah queen bee queen B7 so but
uh how did we do it from a why did it
work when we had went here did you miss
something yeah maybe you can just try
Queen A1 winner one first but no
I mean
I don't know how we blocked after Queen
A1 I just want to go Queen B7 and queen
A7
instead of k98 I I wanted Queen B7 just
uh yeah right but
um but when we went here how did this
work for us did we miss something
ah we missed uh checking somehow in our
line this one yeah so after Queen E5 we
missed King King A8 and then Queen A1
back but here we probably just start
with Queen A7 right like Queen A7 first
and I don't I don't see a how you defend
well I get out of this I'm thinking day
eight can I check you
oh okay but uh okay so you don't have to
give up right so check now you go back
to D7 King B8 oh no I don't have 26 yeah
okay
okay some kind of a triangulation that
is going to work out for us again we're
now us uh we're on the way we're always
on The Winning Side of course let's not
play any bad positions this is move 89
so this has been a really long battle
and I think we're nearing we're nearing
the end can can I do anything else
except for Queen A7
what else can I do can I play
Queen somewhere
24 let's say
no I don't want to love this queen
Queen I want to take your queen away
does this work for me at all because my
idea is I have 27 check and promote so
why did you not gonna C8 then I'm trying
to quit my Pawn Yeah but from C okay so
my point is if any point let's say you
attack my Pawn I always have like
checkout coin okay so I want to see
where you will go so you keep checking
me right I want to go to C6
I feel like we had this position yeah
he played something else
but the idea of King E7 ah I think but
can you tell someone I will continue
yeah but if you pin me I'll just take
your Pawns
that's fair that's enough right yeah uh
so blocks well black needs to find a
move here
um
is after remove
um I think I can just take that right
because if I go here then maybe you
check me or something but yeah maybe
um yeah once the F Pawn disappears it
will take a few more moves but a lot of
your Tactical resources have disappeared
so let's say I get out
I'm trying to make two moves let's say I
run so you go here
and I pin you but now you take this one
to check
so this is even worse and you take this
would have check oh my God Checkers
so I found the worst possible sequence
with this King H6 so this does not work
out at all
and so Queen before black to move and
find a move that doesn't lose
immediately so cannot go here because
after King B7 there is no way for you to
stop
uh this Pawn from queening
am I correct
and in this position no I don't have you
actually threatening so I can I cannot
move my queen
my queen cannot move so I either have to
move a pawn or I have to move so Queen
before is like almost like Silk Swan
it's a it's a nice concept because all
of Black's pieces are perfect and queen
B4 make sure make sure that you have to
do something now and it's not clear what
you're going to do maybe black should
try something like kg7 trying to change
the position as little but C8 is it the
problem is after regular King with
someone you take away this idea and you
don't have G5 because immediately I
trade questions
yeah so
it's amazing every single move makes
your position worse King G7 takes away
Queen G7 G5 it's Queen E4 F3 I I take it
very nice dominant uh he made a move he
came into teenage six isn't this the um
so we went King B7 here
yeah and now there's no Queen G7 because
of this queen of four idea
ah attacking the bishop with a check but
hanging a four was checked I'm starting
to take all your punks correct but am I
taking all your palms
if
King actually Queen this has to be made
right there is no wait no well I I don't
I don't want I don't want to a lot I
didn't realize that I was hanging with a
check but actually let me see if you
take a little check if I go
oh my God there's no checks after King
C7 how is that even possible
I mean I have two queens here one Quinn
oh man so that's how but this is a nice
you know it's constantly finding
resources I think psychologically this
is not easy to do it Queen takes Queen
takes F4 just makes so much sense yeah
he's already played it and then
[Music]
start all over again yeah but
I don't know I'd be so so tempted just
to bail and play Queen H2 and be safe
yeah Queen H2 is the human move but
let's see what he will do he might even
oh he played Queen E4 which is I mean it
keeps his Queen Central and yeah now the
F Pawn has disappeared the fight has
sort of restarted but now there's no
danger oh but this would have been what
a finish this would have been that
yeah
yeah I can't see stuff C7 no checks
Queen f8 comes
no actually you do have a check yeah oh
yeah and then and then King C7 back no
more checks
so you need your king to be in
nostalmate and then you give up your
queen
to win oh man now we're not going to see
this is humans playing not insanity
from what this yeah he's probably just
going to try the same mechanism again
okay
but now I can play but now you don't
really have checks right because so now
if I go to this side so this check is
made with Queen D5 yeah
so now you have to do what queen A5 or
something but uh it's hard to believe
you're not going to lose everyone here
so if I go here
you go Queen B6 I go King D7
um where's my wing and now I really feel
like we're getting ready yeah between
Checkmate here well okay now I take your
check and I can just at this point I can
just yeah it's probably just relax it's
probably just made
yeah this one is very simple
promote variation and I promote
variation so I can move this event can
use seven oh no more checks very nice
and okay this is very similar to with
size so if Queen C1 Queen E5 you can't
go to GA because the bishop on H1 will
arrive on the D5 square and ruin your
day and if you go to H7 we will we will
take your or anywhere on the H5 we'll
take the H Thomas check and this is the
position we have on the board and we
will see a result very soon we're
reaching move 100 what a bottle what a
way to get your way into the playoffs
wow this is this has been an amazing
game went to G8 but now Bishop D5 is
coming right yeah Bishop D5 should wait
he didn't play oh no he went to H7 and
then and then Bishop D5 or Bishop oh no
Bishop D5 was played first then K7 takes
on H2 I'm surprised Christopher is still
playing to be honest with the rich move
um because I think next movie should be
six right
this will be game over but we did reach
move 100
what a battle what a result for
yesterday wins in a row of course this
game is not over yet but
um
Christopher has run out of resources
unfortunately yeah
realizations that we see that I had
chances and it's just all over yeah it
resigns and we see resignation move 100
wow what a game what a battle and we
have a big tie for first place so let's
see our playoff format now that we know
that we have such a big tie for first
place because we're entertaining this
start but
we have uh five player five-way
Armageddon single elimination tournament
so how does how does this work exactly
so I guess
um what what will end up happening is
each player is going to be playing an
Armageddon in the game against each
other and as soon as um as soon as you
lose then you're just you're out of the
you're out of the tournament so there
will so it's going to be like a round
round uh or an elimination style bracket
with Armageddon and then they'll lose
uh so it's five versus four I have
played oh we have oh okay oh someone has
been seated this must be a good time
lyrics then why Tara versus the answer
Casada I'm actually really excited to
see this game because they both you know
like they kind of came back uh to Thai
for first because their last yesterday
he won today he really kind of earned
his place for typher first and he asked
her this epic battle and winning his
game yesterday so the winner of that
match will play Benjamin Park and the
winner of that match will face the
winner of Sabian versus kledura oh also
I've just gotten news that we will see
uh every single game played in this uh
in this tie break they will happen one
at a time so the first matchup we'll get
to see is daro versus Yasir quesada
Perez and Benjamin Bach had great tie
break so yeah he will play the winner of
that matchup and uh Sam seven and uh
Benjamin gladora will be playing their
tie break
and uh
so the high rated player does have a
choice of whether they want to have
white or black I think five versus four
you always and actually I don't know if
there is going to be increment after
move 60 because I remember we were
playing in American Cup and initially it
was no increment and then let them
complained about it so they added
increment after move 60 because he
didn't really like this Armageddon games
or if the pieces are getting thrown off
you know it's no longer chess like we
saw this tournament in Berlin that's
Armageddon where people are players are
pushing cons and then like the file of
the pawn changes and then goes the other
way so Leven really didn't like this and
the American Cup we added one second
increment here we don't have an
increment so it's pure five versus four
which I think has to favor white even
the black
place for two results so we should also
explain to our viewers with an
Armageddon is it's a five versus four so
white gets five minutes black has four
minutes but gets draw odds and uh if the
game ends in the draw that means black
wins so plug is playing for two results
but of course white has an extra minute
on the clock and he's playing
um to also flag their opponent uh so I
think because there is so little time on
the clock we I think five minutes versus
four minutes I think this one minute
difference is actually really
significant and uh personally I would
choose white although people that have
their own preferences depending on their
repertoire and how they feel about their
games so yeah should we try to make some
predictions yeah I I definitely agree
with you I think that white is for
preference in any of these low time
control not no increment style games
just the likelihood that a decisive
result is going to happen I think
outweighs the drawds and the extra time
is kind of nice
um I yeah sure I predict um that Darrow
is going to win against Yasser quesada I
have to go with the with the uh student
um because I think uh I think that he
played for us in the uh the arch Bishops
okay so you're uh choosing the slow
student
and uh let me think what do I want to
choose I kind of want to
when I wrote for Yasser because he did
have this epic win and kind of you know
just want to see him continue doing this
and but I'm also you know I know Daryl
personal a little bit because we played
in US championships and also what's the
question uh Sandler's local so I think
maybe I'll be leaning towards uh Taro
bit although yesterday does he is both
tired but he also has the momentum of
having just won the game and we will be
seeing these games we will be taking a
short break but we will be covering all
the games so please stay with us and we
will be right back with the Playa and we
will Crown the champion
clear
I mean I
okay so this comes with
all right
that's capital of the United States
boasts the world-class St Louis chess
club and the World Chess Hall of Fame it
also plays host to an award-winning shop
dedicated to chess merchandise All
Occasion gifts and plenty more at Q
Boutique you can shop both in store and
online for chess merchandise autograph
Collectibles chess campus souvenirs and
much much more from quirky greeting
cards to luxury chess sets there is
something for everyone at Q Boutique and
all purchases go right to benefiting new
exhibitions and programs at the World
Chess Hall of Fame dedicated to
exploring chess and its immense impact
on art and culture located on the first
floor of the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy a shopping experience like no
other and become everyone's favorite
Gift Giver if you can shop in store make
sure to check out Q boutiquestl.com for
a wide variety of gifts for everyone to
enjoy
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills in
the St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American cop as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also to include
over 2 000 chess lectures for anyone to
enjoy become a member and enjoy perks
such as free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess is
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than
thousand Scouts earning the badge since
2011. students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield anyone can learn how to
understand chess notation in no time we
view chess as a valuable educational
tool learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
it's 2023 and the grand chess tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grantchester hosts a
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best joint
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
sagreb Croatia for the first two rapid
and Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns
foreign
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis City
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
chess classic we are back to see tie
breaks so what do you think about the
tie breaks tattoo I'm really excited to
sit High brakes I
playing in tie bricks but they're really
really see and we have all Armageddon
hybrids which means it's this one game
decides it all the winner moves to the
next one and the loser is eliminated and
let's take a look at what the players
are playing for
and actually there is the title of the
tournament of course and there is the
prize fund and the winner will take the
first place the six thousand dollars so
they are playing for this um six
thousand dollars and everyone else is
going to share the second to the fifth
place funds and so there's a lot of
money on the line and we are going into
this tie break with a five-way tie and
uh we can look take a look at the
bracket and see what we have ahead of us
so our very first game is going to be
Darius Ritz versus the answer quesada
Perez and we have daro with the white
pieces
we will get the moves in a few seconds
like the game will be underway and the
winner of this match is going to play
Benjamin Bach and we will have another
game of some Savion versus Benjamin
gledora so Benjamin Bach gets to rest
for one round and this is actually going
to be a must win game for Darius Ritz
who has the white pieces and will have
five minutes and yasar quesada Perez
will see has four minutes and can
actually move to the second round by
drawing this game
all right so we see the handshake uh
Dara starts with Knight F3
um he's been a English player for most
of this tournament I believe and now
this is an unusual opening Choice he
plays with B3 Bishop B2 a double
double fee and keto so um double fee and
keto against a reverse London system
it's
gives me Nakamura vibes from like
chess.com I know Naco is playing the
setup a lot online well today he played
Knight F3 and when I was talking to him
he said he played some Theory yesterday
it didn't work out well so today he came
to the game thinking I'm just going to
play a game that I don't want to I just
want to be practical and I want to
just get a game and just not go into
deep Theory and he's just doing just
that right Knight F3 P3 G3 and now he is
up on the clock still by a minute and as
long as he gets a comfortable position
where he can make a lot of moves that is
going to be his Advantage so we don't
want what we don't want to allow is a
lot of simplifications we're just as the
white player that is you want to keep
the game going because one of the ways
for why to win this is by just flagging
their opponent yeah I noticed that in
the uh the Knight on C3 is unusual for
this type of setup I know in these ready
positions usually the knights on D2 and
white play C4 so um what do you think
about the Knight on C3 in this position
yeah the night does seem a bit misplaced
I assume the knight at some point will
go to D1 and E3 I think White's idea
will be associated with playing
um F4 at some point so he goes before so
we see
uh there is some uh structural change on
the queen side with this moves A4 B4 and
the key in this kind of position and in
this Armageddon games is getting a lot
of moves in and being comfortable here
so we see the path structure is just
constantly changing now I quite like
Dora's position and his Knight on C3
will re-maneuver itself to D1 and
probably the F2 square and if black
isn't careful I think a very strong Keen
side attack could be generated
yeah the king side attack is one idea by
white here this bishop on H7 I've played
this King side King's Indian attack
positions will I face them with black
and my Bishop is on C8 usually as a
French player it happens in for me 4063
so the bishop on H7 is actually a very
nice defensive piece and we see a lot
more changes have happened complete
structural change as black has exchanged
essential pawns for these past spawns
for this A and B Pawn so there's very
strong pass Pawn on A4 uh connected
Bishop takes D5 is is a very committal
decision but I guess daro thinks that
his uh F and E pawns are the are his
main advantage in this position in the
bishop on G2 doesn't serve a lot of
purpose
so he thinks he has a blockade here but
I think he still needs a few moves so D5
is hanging but A3 is a very strong A3 is
very nice if you take a whole bunch then
Queen C5 at the end Forks The Rook on A3
and the Knight on D4 I wonder if daru
missed this tactical shot yeah I think
he did and Knight D5 runs into Queen B7
again everything else so Bishop C1 only
move so Bishop C1 has oh he took bit
oh he took with the Rook which may
actually I think Rook A3 was the only
move because Bishop C1 also ran into a
fork with something coming to C3
attacking A1 and D4
yeah but the objective evaluation of the
position is not as important as getting
a lot of moves in and whoever has the
easier play so now I see you know this
bishop here and Knight F5 is quite a
nice move
Queen G4
I think black has to face this I think
this was a quite a quite a good
transition for white because the pawn on
A3 was very dangerous and at the cost of
an exchange all of White's pieces are
now very strong I think black is just
getting mated Queen G4 what do you do oh
wow
just take
it's so hard for me to believe that is
Queen H4 F5
can I can I do this am I and then take
one of seven yeah he played your move
Queen G4 very strong daro seems like
he's in he's in control of this position
so he's only up 45 seconds so he has
lost a bit of time but he might just win
on the board so you it's possible for
you to win on the board or on the clock
so if white is a must win situation
because black has draw outs here but uh
G6 was played so I was wondering what
he's thinking but I think Bishop Bishop
D4 might run into Quincy too
yeah I was thinking maybe my E6 move
also also potentially runs into some
Queen C2
can be extremely annoying because uh now
there is some counter play on the second
rank so maybe this actually requires a
lot of accuracy yeah I like your knight
H6 move the more I think about it the
stronger I think that it is uh kg7 runs
into Knight F5 back
and uh now at Knight E7 I think and if
you go to G7 then yeah F5 F6 and you'll
meet me on the H file oh he went 97
immediately
so what is the difference so the reason
why I wanted to take the H Pawn was to
give check on the H file with the queen
later
I'm not so happy about this decision
from
from Darrow it's hard to say because the
position is so complicated maybe uh I
mean this is me how how does he defend
himself F6 is made he took only five
only move
uh and if F takes G6 you take how do you
take if you take this way can I
take
what's happening
oh he took only seven yeah that's that's
very clever defending everything because
now when you take on G6 f8 is f8 is
sorry it's not hanging anymore and white
should be okay this is very unfortunate
because I I think this runs into some
Perpetual so he has to take only move
now he has to take on a fate yeah and
white does not have draw odds black has
drawn so it seems very likely that
schweirtz is is not going to not going
to win this game there is a
yeah but Perpetual is the same as a loss
so playing this Perpetual would be I
mean the same as resigning but he
doesn't have any other move yeah he can
go Queen D5 Queen F7 he has to come our
F1 so you can play Queen G2 but then P3
yeah Dora missed missed a huge shot I
think I think he'll regret not playing
Knight H6
I mean of course after he looks at this
game it
Knight H6 but over the board it's so
hard to make this decision because this
position is just so complicated and the
position we have on the board Queen f8
played and I think here he is realizing
that he doesn't have anything better
than a perpetual and as we saw after
Queen D5 Queen F7 the queen very
annoyingly also defends The Rook even
though even if I could yeah
so you have to try something like Queen
G2 here like even if objectively you're
dead lost
um playing Perpetual is the same as
resigning and I mean they're playing for
so much money uh he just plays Perpetual
but yeah I mean unfortunately this is
resignation
so quesada Perez makes it into the next
round after that epic win against
Christopher you he wins another game so
I think
you know he's on a roll now
yeah a very nice very nice defense I
mean uh it's so easy in a position where
your opponent is just attacking your
king to totally collapse but he kept us
cool and even if objectively he was lost
he played very practically and very fast
and his opponent wasn't able to convert
in time pressure and now he has another
game against Benjamin Park coming up but
we can go back and take at that take a
look at that critical moment
once the game start of course we'll go
back to the game and in this position
again it's so easy to make these moves
when you are not the one under pressure
because this position is just so
complicated if we just pause and look at
this this is hanging this is hanging
with some potential mates on the second
rank this king is of course is just very
vulnerable
and thorough calculated some kind of a
precise line and he missed something
which is what happened in the game so
what we want to play is this move the
king h8 this looks after Bishop D4 E6 is
coming this looks extremely dangerous
yeah in Queen Ridge Queen H3 something
like this it's still I mean okay because
E6 is coming and the Knight F7 is kind
of yeah this is very strong
yes I'm very very precise moves need to
be made here yeah E6 would be in check
is is convenient I think a nice line in
that position was um if you continue
down that path like Queen H Queen H3
Queen C2 um queen queen takes D3 then I
have E6 check
um and if you take on D4 I have Knight
F5 check and I collect your queen
yeah but uh with seconds left on your
clock it's so difficult to make uh but
uh also when you have you know when
you're playing those time Odds Games you
start my getting games and you're ahead
on the clock you you just want to stay
ahead on the clock because if you lose
this time of advantage
then you're just playing for
um you know your opponent is playing for
two results and they have no
disadvantages so their main disadvantage
is you have a minute on the clock you
can flag them so if everything is even
and there is no time difference then you
know the odds are really in their favor
but this was a critical moment and just
not enough time to for him to figure out
if this was a classical game then I
think Dara would have won quite
comfortably but unfortunately in the
Blitz game anything is anything is
possible
and actually let's see what happens so
97 at 595 only move and yeah this is
this was the problem because he gave his
opponent only moves to make because
there's nothing else he can do this will
run into
some kind of a Checkmate right yeah five
Bishop D4 yeah Bishop D4 is easy enough
I think all kinds of Checkmate so he
gave him this option and
counterintuitive leaving your opponent
with this bishop but without that Knight
there is no attack and
and we have a perpetual and
yeah Perez does move to play Benjamin
Park and our next game is about to start
so we will move on to that game
so it's going to be seven against
gladora they're going to give yaser
quesada Perez a chance to rest in
between Armageddon games of course he
had this whole game with Christopher you
so a well-deserved rest and now we will
get to see Sabian against godora yeah he
might just be playing on pure adrenaline
at this point you know he played that
long game and now he has to play another
game there's no time for him to rest but
his his winning he's won three games the
last three games he's played he's won so
he's uh he's on the streak so collateral
White against Savion same situation must
win game for white actually I think it's
it's uh is the graphic Chrome because I
think it's seven against no I think
collateral I can tell from uh okay so
glitter is playing white seven is black
yes sir graphic is not correct I can I
can also see from the waist Savion is
sitting that it's him
why to win in this game Draw means that
Savion advances
uh so mostly the game for Benjamin
godura and he actually had a lot of time
to rest his game ended rather quickly so
he must be very well rested but said I'm
also coming off Victory and you know
this um these things actually can make a
difference because it's momentum
and the games will start any seconds
yes I've been a very exciting player I
think the most number of wins uh it's
pretty wins and losses in this
tournament have come from come from him
to to get here
so we're awaiting the start of this
route at any moment
um
any moment now the Arbiter will start
the clock and what is our prediction for
this game we see a handshake the time
Stars night at 3d5 V3 no G3 popular
popular choice Knight of three in these
tie breaks so probably D4 here planar
reverse Gruden fellow
Castle yeah what was it found this line
to be a bit dangerous for uh for black
but E3 is an unusual choice I know that
C4 is the main move for white and black
plays the move Bishop to D7
um getting ready to face some future C4s
because a lot of times in this positions
after C4 is played that's by C uh
there's some issues for black on the
diagonal due to the h1a diagonal and now
he's developing his Bishop but sadly to
start playing a little quicker he cannot
be spending too much time on move 7 is
getting behind he's still a minute
behind oh B5 yeah just controlling the
C4 square and it's interesting to note
that white in both of these Armageddon
games
um has chosen to play very slow solid
systems that aim to play like a long
game which makes a lot of sense because
if you play a lot of moves then your
extra minute is going to count for a lot
so I think this is very clever by both
Darrow and Glendora I think is the right
approach to this format and the thing is
it's a Blitz game four against five now
it's four against three so at some point
something is going to happen when you
have no time mistakes come uh something
something happens it doesn't matter if
it's a tactical blunder positional
blunder whatever it is you know some
miscalculation it's going to happen
there's just not enough time to figure
everything out
but having extra time is of course very
helpful and again getting a lot of moves
in this is very important so Sam is
still a minute behind on the clock so he
has not made any improvements in that
regard but his position does seem quite
comfortable so he can make up for it in
future moves maybe in the future you can
play five I think next is going to
Castle
no matter what so his position feels
very comfortable he has more space his
pieces are
developed everything is where it's
supposed to be so Bishop on C1 doesn't
leave a very good impression every
single Pawn in White's position is on a
dark square and the bishop currently has
zero legal moves so for the special to
develop he will have to either remove
the B Pawn or remove the Knight and I
also like this configuration of the
queen and Bishop on the diagonal because
um oh it's a very nice move by Sam Sam
plays the move A5 controlling the B4
square and um uh I I do say I quite like
Black's position at the moment yeah
Black's position is very comfortable
it's very easy for him to find his moves
and the white is struggling so now we
see clocks are getting closer it's
actually 3 12 to 307 so white is losing
the main advantage so in this position
white is both force on the board and
also on the clock
has dropped and draw it so everything I
think is in Black's favor right now yeah
but now the position might be opening up
you should be
as a French player whenever I put my
Bishop on E8 I feel like I'm doing well
uh A5 very dominating wolf impossible to
G4 developed so he goes for G4 yeah
white is lashing out at this point
because you need to generate counter
play somewhere if you just remain worse
on all sides of the board and you're
going to get slowly crushed but
um I don't I don't necessarily like this
push because you do weaken the I mean G4
G5 weekends the F5 square and the King
side will become a bit soft and I like
how Sam is playing the way he's playing
is just so dominant he's playing so
quickly his moves are so good he's
getting ready to play E5 aiming at the
queen he doesn't care about this attack
uh uh maybe he plundered some Bishop D5
but he goes back with the queen brings
the queen closer and he's getting ready
to go E5 95 huge thread by black
the queen looks looks very funny
on that side of the board also A5 may be
a bit listening
so it's actually a big decision for some
because you know part of you wants to
play active and wants to play um
against what your opponent is doing but
the other part of your nose you have
draw outs right
and uh that that's that's a good point
so Sam chooses to play uh more calm
probably due to the um the format of the
tournament I'm sure in a classical game
he would have he would have tried to
punish uh White Moore in playing in the
center than he has in this game Rook A5
I like to smoke but now why this up
so
not living a great impression but at
least white got upon and now black has a
proof that he has some compensation for
it this king is also very weak
and you know there's some draw odds so
Bishop G5 might be some kind of a threat
in the future B4 was a nice move by
white though taking advantage of the
fact that opposite wasn't possible due
to the Rook on A5 being hanging so black
played the move Rook D5 and there is
some long-term potential for white so at
the moment his position isn't very good
but I think that um
uh if he manages to survive the next few
moves then uh it'll be white who uh who
might even have winning wait this is a
blunder okay1 22.
he's on some wow
yeah this is a big what is it
calculating it's calculating group D2
probably but this this is just a piece
yeah Rook B1 uh oh no he has quit he's
calculating this oh this is what he's
calculating
and King goes up yeah the issue uh do I
have I must have some Perpetual here
right there's no way nice yeah there's
there's good it's good enough so he
finds it yeah queen queen
I know he's still thinking about Queen
D2 but he he I'm sure that this is the
reason why Sam play this line and after
Rook B1 you probably just take on B4
with the queen and then A3 comes and
that should be game over oh he even
takes with the Rook wait oh there is no
Queen yeah Bishop f8 rugby one uh we
missed he did spend a bit of time so
he's done on time
not his
uh he's doing well on the board Bishop
D4 nice chance
takes
and queen before ah okay so he plays he
plays very safe so draw it's being very
important here he does have
um less time than his opponent though so
glador has made
um has made up some ground in this game
I think I I feel like um instead of Rook
before black should have played Queen B4
earlier I'm not sure how white was
defending against that but
um but we're here now so bishop f8 and
safety is key here he's very happy with
the draw
so but still down on time you know you
can just Vlog your opponent you just
have to play Fast right uh glador is
thinking here
um okay so H6 yeah so now if you can
reverse the battery somehow then he
would be doing very well but it
obviously takes time for uh for white to
rearrange his pieces in such a way
and if he moves his Queen then he's
going to run into a lot of checks on the
back rank so there is no chance to do
this but what can I go Queen D1 13 Queen
G4 yeah Queen D1 I think is what he's
going to do oh Queen E1 yeah
yeah very precise Sam plays well under
pressure but still this time difference
the stand difference making me so
nervous it's only five seconds at this
point since I think yeah no quick if you
need to Sam play faster
85. no queenish five literally yeah but
you know you can't you can't just play
this you can just play this for
Queen H5 I think was impossible because
the queen was up no no I want to go upon
it oh oh yeah yeah that was but they're
not these young players they play so
much online I think they're so used to
this Armageddon position 64 very nice
yeah no it's no it should be pretty safe
now you you should never lose this
position anymore so it's going to become
an insane time Scramble now take take
and yes
oh man Sam is trying to win this
position I'd be obsessed queen of six uh
now you now you can't nice wow Sam's
having a well-deserved victory in this
in this Armageddon playoff what a game
what a game what a turnaround that we
saw at this moment
if I can't find it yeah let's uh
this moment when he went Bishop D2
and I think some spend the time
calculating Queen E5 but I think after
bishop f8 and you take here so first of
all I can pick up your Bishop yeah but
at the very least I must have a
Perpetual yeah it's arming it's
Armageddon so uh probably instead of
yeah instead of
taking a draw right given checks on the
side right like just forever Queen yeah
Star Wars
but I'm very surprised I have a
Perpetual here I'm sick I'm very
surprised that he took on B4 with the
Rook uh wasn't Queen B4 just winning the
piece by force
I like uh yeah rookie one Queen D2 Rook
B1 and then queen of four and
um A3 is coming next Bishop f8 so eight
six again but H6 uh I should be able to
and once this bishop is of support then
there is no more checks wow
congratulations actually
um I don't know if you would have made
it in the final position and queen is
fun to win the game but because wide run
out of pieces the game ended there is no
way for white to win so it doesn't
matter what the result is it's either a
draw or a win if black would manage to
Queen his pawn and win the game or a
drop just by default and
some Savion moves to the next round and
he's going to be facing the winner of
quesada Perez and um
Benjamin Park yeah
yeah so some Serbian moves the next spot
and Benjamin Park
playing his first Armageddon game in
this tournament so Benjamin block
probably the most well-rested player at
this point in time he has rested all the
way up until this point through the Army
get it matches and see his game with
gladora was was pretty quick and it
actually ended before our broadcast came
on
yes so let's see who will have the white
pieces so we saw that
Sada he
uh the black pieces Lions game he
survived the storm so I'm curious to see
what is going to happen I think that's
Benjamin with the white pieces
from what I see I can tell I think
Benjamin is white so yeah I think one
more uh one more game that he needs to
survive you're more familiar with the
players than I am you could just tell by
looking I I still don't really know my
body language how these how these
players act yeah sometimes like from a
mannerisms or from the way the players
are sitting I can't tell who it is
especially with the star players because
I've seen them so many times but uh
so they're figuring out the digital to
make sure everything works and they see
the black player is a bit nervous taking
his leg but who isn't I'm nervous just
watching this
uh so let's see if we have any
predictions here what's what's going to
happen in this game yeah I think
um
so now it's really hard to root against
yesterday quesada Perez just every game
he plays off adrenaline and he's won his
last three games
um I'm gonna switch it up I think Yasser
quesada Perez is going to defeat
Benjamin Bach even though I would I'm in
my heart I'm rooting for Benjamin Bach
as he's an arch he's he's an Archbishop
and uh it's hard to root against my
teammates who else oh but every time
yeah so he's the only one standing in
this tournament yeah so I'm I'm
predicting the quesada quesado when such
that Bach will win proving me wrong
and we do have some moves again Knight
F3 and this is a repeat of the last game
but no C4 yeah so C4 instead of this um
B3 Bishop B2 Knight C3 system so now
this is a more
um a more thematic way to play this
ready position I believe they play
Bishop E3 yeah to play this sort of end
game with the Double B pawns and this is
considered be slightly unpleasant for um
for black
and I'm not getting the moves on my end
so we will be watching the game on the
Stream
and we see the time difference still a
minute on the cloud Benjamin is playing
very quickly he seems to know this
position really well the idea is to put
a knight on A5 put a lot of pressure
on the Block structure and the other
Knight can go to D4 so all the pieces
are headed towards the queen side here
right yeah I think a lot of the play is
associated around the B7 and C6 pawns
being slightly weak in this position
that's why Rick be it was played to over
defend the B7 Pawn but uh okay white is
thinking would otherwise he had a huge
advantage on the clock so Knight equals
35 anyways putting pressure on the pond
so at some point white might even be
able to play B5 well now here's an
option he can take with the Knight or
the Palm oh if he takes it upon 94 is
coming so he might have to say goodbye
to that Bishop
kind of I I kind of like Knight takes
better just I don't want to give Knight
E4 as you are pointing it out but okay
he decides the 94 isn't isn't as big of
a deal as having these double isolated V
pawns long term
of a new safe suspicio people is Bishop
U1 and now his Bishop is is safe so
maybe this was just the best of all
worlds oh I love this kind of move and
now we see why Rook fc1 is good yeah
your favorite Bishop it should be it you
should be one this is you know how you
should be developing this pieces so now
we see the pizza pan is hanging maybe it
will Gateway as possible uh this bishop
on H7 can prove to be an annoying piece
to face because it's eyeing this long
diagonal
here uh how to defend this Pawn do I
want to play something like rookie2
box position seems uh quite passive
because you you know there's this pin p7
is hanging you cannot really do anything
about this you can never move this Pawn
C6 is hanging
might something might happen on this
diagonal instead he played Knight D4 uh
C5 was a nice move from from black so
even though the pawns were doubled on B4
and B2 black trades off the double Pawn
because it's more important to gain some
space and
change the structure with black rather
than just being passive and waiting
around for white to determine what he
wants to do oh momentum
so important in this game and now the
Black Knight is going to land on D3 F2
is hanging and maybe the E4 night so now
Knight D3 expect
unless I'm missing something no what
happened oh so he took on D1 and play
rookie yeah these drawers once again uh
black was very happy with the draw and
uh the more pieces you exchange the more
likely it is we're going to see that
result
and now Knight D3 is going to be even
more annoying because the bishop 21 is
actually under attack so this was
actually a very unpleasant change for
white because not the flow of the game
changes he was pressing he was pressing
and now he has to keep the game going in
a way that he still has the winning
chances because again white needs to win
this game I must say I I think esada
Perez is a very good Defender every
every game we've seen in play he's under
some sort of pressure yesterday Guard
from some sort of checks and he he's
been up to the task in in every game and
I mean to be fair every game the same
place being with the black pieces
yeah but I agree he's uh he's doing
really really well pressured so
luxuration once uh we zoom in so it's
259 to 216 so getting a bit closer this
needs to be playing a little bit faster
and there's so many nights on the board
it's always so scary with the Knights
the bishop on H7
oh Knight V2 tagging C4 but
upon move not or the pond did move got a
lot of moves in
yeah I don't know
um who I'd even prefer at this point
because on the one hand the pawn on C5
could be could be scary on the other
hand
um the a pawn could run and also so I
think the Tactical reason why this is
possible is if you take on C5 twice then
white has this bishop B4 idea which is
why black did not opt to take the C5
Pawn with that said black does have the
outside pass pawn and um at the very
least very good drawing chances
so he's trying he's really determined to
exchange pieces and I do like that he
set up his piece before he hit his clock
there are too many players that knock
over the pieces and just hit the clock
and expect you you know expect the game
to keep going on but uh that is uh not
allowed so he did set up his piece like
like a gentleman would well he's finding
every move to exchange pieces and so for
example if Knight D3 Bishop D3 King goes
to G2 and I think A5 is coming to stop
this Bishop from joining the game and
now King is seven King d6's going to
come next so I see Benjamin is nervous
and I think he should be because
position is not doing great it's just
he's up on the clock A5 playing very
quickly he's only up 30 seconds
on the board objectively he's not doing
any better than his opponent but this is
an Armageddon game A5 is very nice
because it also stops Bishop B4 check
from being a thing and now the king can
come to D6 and I think that's why Bishop
B2 is played now you can meet keaney
seven with the move Bishop to A3 but you
have to be careful because
um Bishop A3 could be a tactic at some
point anyway because C7 comes but
luckily we still have Bishop A6 to guard
against the C Pawn we want if F4 trying
to open the diagonal F6 keeps the
balance in the position black is doing
great positionally so it's just a matter
of not getting behind on the clock he's
not too behind but again once the clocks
start running low anything can happen so
I expect if four is possible
I don't think there is a problem with A4
just make decisions quick yeah you need
to play for quickly though and this
could still end up in a in a very
bizarre time scramble you need to be so
careful yeah Bishop A6 nice save oh King
the seven Bishop E6 would have been a
nasty tactics we'll take a look at it
when we get the chance
yeah so now Black is Black is doing
great that fun is running that pawn is
falling yeah you take the take the C7
Pawn oh he's reaching for Bishop because
if you check first then we could have
maybe dislodged the king but Bishop
season seven is just safer not risking
any tactics Bishop D3 attack yeah Bishop
D31 yeah I like Bishop D3 a lot just
play quickly but he's afraid that King
will run to G6 so E4 on the kingdom one
to G6 so this is I think King G6 yeah
yeah it's just those practical decisions
oh Bishop before he won the bishop
before no no no oh the tightest the
tightest changed yeah King D6 was a big
mistake
[Music]
yeah and you have no time and this is
the big risk now White's probably going
to win this game oh that was
heartbreaking so well but uh no this
will be objectively lost the bishop only
five so dominant and
whoa okay
three again and uh
Bishop C1 yeah yeah you just lose H6 and
it's gonna be two white has so much time
takes this uh this is heartbreak
heartbreaking to see of course there had
to be a winner at some point the game is
not over yet to be fair but uh you know
when you see someone doing really well
we don't like to see huge blunders we
like to see beautiful games so this is a
bit heartbreaking to see someone just
wander
maybe he will meet him
yes he has himself made in some in some
way but yeah five and it's just all over
H5 is coming and the pawns will will
Queen eventually
okay he starts with G5 which makes sense
um there's no juice made yeah G6 Bishop
page
uh he's he's trying a bit Yeah but
unfortunately the position doesn't offer
a whole lot of fights to seven
yeah yeah it's not enough time
that was heartbreaking wow
so Benjamin Bach will be playing Sam
Seville in the um in the final
really really exciting format I gotta
say these these games go really fast and
they're super exciting and I'm I'm kind
of a big fan of this playoff format the
old tournament should just be four which
is five harm I get in this is uh all
tournament just going forward there was
a key moment we wanted to look at in
this game but so it was uh what was the
key moment that we saw something yeah
black played so well up till this point
yeah he was still defending so he was
just exchanging everything A5 dominating
this bishop
and then F4 he's trying to do something
on the diagonal he said no but we did
say that
this became a problem
King is seven and this was the key
moment he did not play gt7 running into
Bishop E6 and queen yeah that would be
very unfortunate and he said he played
Bishop A6 it's great move and we see
here that he goes for the punt but you
know this is a very practical decision
for white even if you somehow
um I think maybe he should have gone for
check and this in this position
I like I like what he did I just think
that King D6 was was a was a bad mistake
like here uh if you don't play King D6
and play something like Bishop D6 oh so
he played King D6 and Bishop before no
King to six
um knife she checked uh no no I mean
like later oh like here he played King
D6 or something to that effect yeah yeah
before yeah I think but here I mean this
is so easy to
yeah I oh the reason why he did that was
he wanted to go Bishop B6 Bishop D4
yeah but I think in this position it's
already hard to maybe A2
but A2 I will take
uh okay my point was I wanted to go
Bishop A5 and try to chase you on the
diagonal so Bishop C7
all the way and then uh
maybe now yeah maybe it actually was
much harder than I thought it was
um you need to be able to play King E6
Bishop B5 I was gonna say now maybe a
bishop sorry King D6 is is better than
than it was before but but now that I've
taken this many pawns I might give up my
bishop and then put my king on the dark
square and just push my Pawn no I I
think in this position once the Kink
um
once the king got to G6 I think
practically this is already
psychologically this is very difficult
because there's no way you can calculate
what happens after you lose this pawns
even if you somehow get a bishop and
this was a great uh Choice by
Benjamin in this position going if
walking before and just completely
forgetting everything here so kind of
tying black down to the queen side and
going for this uh ponds yeah that's a
that's a really good point yeah after
King G6 it's probably it's pretty
difficult to play Flex position
I wonder if you could instead of playing
Bishop D3 maybe you could start with the
E4 I don't know if this is really smart
or really stupid what is the idea the
whole point is that your Pawn's not on
e4 yet so
um if you take with the with the bishop
then then I will play too
and if you um is this so scary uh I
thought
oh now you can put a
yeah something like this and if you go
King G6 and I have Bishop E4 or now I'm
just blundering everything
what we're at this position before but
we saw a version of this before right
yeah
Bishop A5 the bishop G7 again yeah yeah
now I can then come on hide
and maybe you defend and I can never
take this Pawn but yeah still
practically it's hard to play play uh
here
oh but yeah if you go King F6 I can play
A1 yeah no but uh what I think happened
is uh White played really practical
moves going to get five trying to go for
this queen side so black doesn't really
have time to run there
because if you try
I will just check you so we see similar
to what happened so he played moves that
make a lot of sense but Bishop D3 I
think just helps quite because I have an
only four and my Bishop is reinforced
stopping your bishop and now that my
king runs to this side you can never
check me and I can never do anything so
I think the rest of the game was really
well played by white and King District's
a very unfortunate blunder because now
your entire King side Falls because your
Bishops are just on the other side of
the board
and he just takes everything he just
literally took every Pawn
and now the Palms are simply too much
yeah very unfortunate yeah really
heartbreaking way for the game to end
but it is Armageddon and it is what
happens when there are not that many
pieces on the board when there's not uh
that many minutes minutes on the clock
and uh it's been determined the bach
will be playing with the white pieces
against Sam Sabian so uh colors have
been determined Bach is going to be
plain white so he's in
Savion once again has the draw arts and
both players coming off of a win so I'm
saving defending actually it wasn't
defending he was always on the better
side of that position and Benjamin Bach
coming off a win in this time scramble
and keeping his nerves and doing a
really good job of converting that game
and turning the tables so this is going
to be a very close game Let's uh let's
go ahead and take a look at the uh the
prize fund again because they are
playing for quite a bit of money in the
final uh first place is six thousand
dollars and second place will be a
combination from second through fifth of
all the prizes added up and divided so
it's about uh
26 uh 25. yeah so this is the money
money game The Winner Takes six thousand
dollars and the non-winter takes twenty
six hundred dollars so this is there's
thirty five hundred dollars on the line
and one Armageddon game but uh this is
how it works we have to have a winner
and uh you know people like to see
winners
clear clear winner
no chops in this tournament my system is
already sitting at the board and
Benjamin is not there yet we're going to
start the game in a second now what's
your prediction for this for this game
uh you've asked me every time I think
I'm gonna I'm picking some I don't know
how it will happen but I'll pick some
yeah it's hard to root against Sam based
off his performance in the last game so
you just changed your uh opinion so
quickly like oh archbishops on here like
ah now you know I'm rooting for Bach but
I think Sam will win
[Music]
again I think five position is very
comfortable
castles but not I'm not getting the
moves yet but yeah I should be able to
in a few minutes everyone has chosen a
slow setup with uh with white in this
Army getting are we getting game I do
like White's position here I think after
black moves as Bishop wait we'll play
something like C4 and I think you get
something uh something close to a
Queen's Gambit accepted
so saying some offbeat openings does
make sense because if you play a lot of
theory and you let your opponent get a
lot of moves in immediately then that's
very helpful for them because they are
low on the time so they make a lot of
moves
so if black can get in E5 he'll be very
happy but now the Rooks will go to D1
and C1 and C4 will come and it's a
matter of where black is going to be
putting his Queen Pockets chosen to play
Bishop D3 and queen C2 so I wonder if
now he's opting for eie4 instead of C4
so his last few moves indicated that E4
was specifically for him but also B5
outright prevented C4 from being a move
and I wonder if at some point he's going
to play five close the position which of
course will also block
um like his Bishop but at the same time
maybe there will be some hopes of the
attacks I think H4 will come at some
point with the idea of E5 Knight G5
maybe yeah I think E5 maybe you can try
Knight H5 with the idea that Knight F4
is Knight F4 is coming
I'm not totally sure
love my night pinks
pinks three and then and the night jumps
but oh Benjamin's spending a lot of time
in this position so he has some kind of
a decision to make so he decides to take
a big decision so 95 now we have those
two menacing Bishops and now the queen
will end up on the king side so the G6
yeah this diagonal is going to be very
weak and um black needs to be very
careful not to blunder tactics
associated with the bishop on B2 not C4
comes now that the D5 Pawn is gone C4 is
on the port
and this position is starting to feel
comfortable for white Now The Rook will
go on D1 white white just has a lot of
central pressure Rook D1 Bishop
somewhere yeah just a lot of squares so
if we take you cannot take with the
queen because Knight D6
are
so you will take with the Knight and
then maybe Queen H4 will come right if
the queen goes to age oh wow but yeah as
you pointed out Knight D6 looks looks
like a good move and at the very least
we might be able to win a pawn oh
three yeah we both
is a good move but a lot of moves are
coming yeah Sam is very accurate with
this with his calculations even even in
time pressure what did Benjamin play
he played Rook C1
okay so it seems like uh Sam has
rerouted his knight from E7 and is
planning to go to F5 yeah he did that in
the last game too oh yeah
yeah the same Maneuvers keep popping up
uh throughout this entire tournament um
very nice exchanges black just wants to
exchange but no it's uh you know this A6
Pawn may become a better weakness don't
forget the bishop on F1
but generally I think this exchanges
should be good for black getting rid of
some of the tension yeah Knight F5 might
run into a move like Queen to B6 which
targets all of the all oh wow so he
indicated he wanted to play Bishop C6
but instead instead has played the move
Bishop to D5
[Music]
I think the bishop hangs but not the A6
Pawn hangs two so there's some Queen B2
line yeah Queen B2 has been played
um my bar tells me it's a mistake but I
have no idea why because it looks like a
normal move to me what did he do yeah he
played negative four
so booting the queen out of out of uh B2
so yeah this doesn't this doesn't feel
great because if we can just take take
A6 somehow then uh their positions will
be very nice Knight F5 but is this a big
deal there's some background issues I
see that maybe Knight H4 Knight F3 can
lead to Checkmate oh United for Knight
H4 Knight F3 is a good idea because of
takes then Queen G5 could pork the
Canaan Rook on C1 so I'm not getting the
most so let's see what's on the board
yeah Queen G5 and yeah now white needs
to be really careful about his Pawn on
G2 because there's only the bishop on F1
defending and uh lots of tactics could
happen but I don't see how wide it's
going to hang on to this
um
going to hang on to this A6 Pawn how do
you defend this Pawn because
as long as I keep my keep my queen on
the third any Knight H4 we met with
Queen G3 and otherwise oh C5 okay I got
an answer to my question I stopped
receiving moves on my end unfortunately
oh now I'm receiving them again Knight
D7 oh Knight F6 Knight F6 is a huge
threat and very hard to admit this move
because
yeah Bishop J2 doesn't work yeah
and now we're running into some huge
tactical problems
and the clocks are getting even but the
positionally this is looking really bad
Knight F6 taking on D5 is an option and
after that I've seen the king just does
not have a move because the queen will
be hanging
yeah oh that's that's a funny tactic
neither six Knight H7 I saw the other
idea which was to just take on D5 and
play Queen h8 and take the Rook on C8 so
there are a lot of
threats in this position for white maybe
you have to play a move like F6 and Kane
F7 but I don't really believe this
should be three okay it feels like this
runs into Knight F6 and your knight H7
move Knight F6 and then I
I know what his idea is oh oh my oh wow
is there a fortress can you take on A5
yeah I don't and the pawn is running the
bishop won F1 we're an annoying piece
this Rooks you want an option at all
yeah I think that the position would be
a draw if the Knight on F5 were were
traded for the bishop well he's a very
professional players when they knock
over their pieces in this event and pick
and pick them back up yeah it's actually
a cut proof of mine when people
yeah me too of course
something is going to fall the night
will move Queen B7 will pick up a piece
yeah when you're playing against the
queen you really want your pieces to be
defended and not not able to be attacked
um in the night on night on D6 is just
hanging into all sorts of things you
also want to have more pieces yeah
you want to have way more than this oh
looks lost at this point
and this looks like white is cruising I
don't see what black can do at this
point
yeah black is just a massive trouble A7
is you might even be
um no I mean A7 is just coming and it's
over yeah no reason to be fancy or
anything
Knight C8
it gives up this too okay keeps the game
going well here's the option
of course yeah because it's just so
useless yeah the bishop could have come
to D5 and made his life hard but now
it's now it's just over oh yeah oh my
goodness
yeah congratulations to Benjamin Bach
winning the tournament
um he was in a bit of trouble in his
previous game against yester quesada
Perez but uh yeah Benjamin Bach went six
thousand dollars from that game
most incredible performance yeah and his
decision to make a quick
dry his opponent
s but a really nice Victory by him he
won some really spectacular games in
this tournament and actually we forgot
to mention that he beat Savion in the
classical portion of the tournament and
once again he beat him in the Armageddon
so that's one memorable game that I have
that he was talking about and the other
one was against Yasser quesada Perez
where he had that queen versus three
pieces so we know he has a lot of
experience playing with a quiz against
miners so he's done um I don't know his
uh he knows how to win this position so
really great performance by him winning
this super strong tournament with a
with a plus one score and winning both
of the games in the Armageddon so
congratulations to Benjamin yeah and
while we're waiting for an interview
um it's important to mention that our
next tournament is going to be the Super
bets um Blitz I believe which will sorry
super of it and chess classic my mistake
which will be happening May 6th
the tour is going to be five tournaments
starting in Romania and ending in San
Luis the last two tournaments will be
the Saint Louis rapid and Blitz and the
sinful cup
which will take place in November in St
Louis so this is going to be a very
exciting tour including many of the top
players not Magnus Carlson but the newly
crowned world champion will play as both
dingler and and Yani Pon this year are
scheduled to play in the tour so let's
go ahead and take a look at what that
would uh look like
it's 2023 and the grand chest tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grand Jester hosts the
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best joined
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
sagreb Croatia for the first two rapid
and Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American cop as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that all to include over
2 000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
thank you
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Hue Boutique and all purchases go right
to benefiting new exhibitions and
programs at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
thank you
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2
team the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than 250
000 Scouts earning the badge since 2011.
students of chess can also pick up a
copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield anyone can learn how to
understand chest notation in no time we
view chess as a valuable educational
tool learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
oh
welcome back everyone I am here with
Benjamin bug who just won the Armageddon
two armageddens to clinch the title for
group a so congratulations Benjamin how
do you feel uh yeah it feels amazing uh
yeah yeah it feels amazing feels great
of course the wind event
um yeah I knew it was not going to be
easy and uh I felt like my main
competitor was going to be Savion I've
actually also played him in the World
Cup in 2021 and the match it also went
down to the wire so it feels great to
get my uh revenge and uh yeah I feel it
feels great to win the vent overall
and you started the tournament with a
loss
[Music]
and as you described it the perfect game
where you had that amazing preparation
and then you won that Visa versus night
position and then today you decided to
make a quick drop where you're hoping
you'd go into tie breaks did you think
you had a better chance or why didn't
you wanna
try beating your opponent yeah it's a
good question so yeah I felt like
um I I just kind of wanted to get the
tournament over with I felt like I
played a good event I didn't wanted to
to spoil it in the last round and I
figured okay in the in the tie break
I'll all get my chances
um of course I knew that a lot of people
could join for a tie break
up to six people that ended up being
five and I wasn't even sure what the
format was gonna be but yeah my I
figured okay I I just wanted to log in
share it first and a good event
um and yeah that was basically my my
thought process going in into the game
like I just didn't want to take big
risks into going into this uh this game
and um yeah he ended up playing very
solidly and so yeah then we went for
this repetition and I was I was fine
with it so I don't necessarily have any
real regrets well not after this right
not after this of course but even after
the game even when I saw many people
winning I I kind of regretted not
winning yesterday against Mishra that
was a little bit uh annoying because I
felt like that like I had great chances
to win the game and if I win that game I
think I have great chances to win the
event
um
but yeah today I I felt like just just
playing it solid and we'll see what
happens in a Tariq so one of
oh you didn't think he would win with
the black pieces right it was probably a
thought process so what kind of
realistically what were you expecting
because it's hard to expect so many
players to win and have this huge tie
break right yeah so by the time I
finished my game I thought that well
first I thought Christopher you was a
bit worse and then he got a better
position and then he blundered uh so so
yeah when he got a better position I was
a little bit worried I was I was saying
like oh I hope he doesn't uh win and
just win event overall and then he
blunted and of course that's very
important for him but I was happy to see
it
um and uh yeah it was I I thought
there's a good chance that at least one
player would join like two you you never
know
um but I thought that there would be a
good chance we would play Ty break with
four players but yeah I've never had
I've never had an event where there's a
five-way tie for first and five out of
nine wins you the event
it's like half of the tournament times
for first place yeah this was a very
entirely contested tournament and let's
talk about this Armageddon so in your
first game so you actually got seated
into the next round because of your good
tie break so you didn't play the first
game and uh you chose to play White and
you actually chose to play White in both
games so why did you choose to play
white instead of getting the draws
I feel like it's just a little bit
easier to play with why you have an
extra minute on the clock which
definitely counts for something and you
get the white pieces and I feel with why
you know I'm just going to go all out
and try to play quickly try to put as
much pressure as possible whereas with
black you can easily start hesitating
like should I play solid should I play
for the win uh so I feel like it's in a
way easier to play with white like you
know what you have to do and I I feel
like one minute is definitely a
significant Advantage especially over
the board when you play online you know
you can make up with pre-moves at the
end but over the board if you have uh 10
seconds against the 30 you're just gonna
lose and I think
like white has a huge Advantage right
because the time is so little so at
which point do you think that it becomes
a little more even with the time
difference it's a very good question so
I think at World Cups they often have
the time control where y gets five
minutes and black gets four minutes but
there is two seconds of increment after
move 60. so I asked Mike whether there
was an increment at any point during the
game and he said no so then I knew okay
I'm just gonna pick uh pick white
um I think maybe something like six
versus five is around even but I think
five versus four white should definitely
have an advantage so you think this
increment makes a huge difference
because we had these conversation during
last year American Cup and 11 was very
insistent about this increment because
he thought at some point it's just not
just anymore because we said we see
these games right the piece is rolling
and uh so you think without increment
you just always choose white in the same
control I think five versus four you you
should pick white yeah so let's quickly
talk about your game so they were very
quick games I don't know how
memory because I know it's pure
adrenaline so in this first game uh so
the position let's go to this bishop end
game so at this point when all of this
this A5 happens how are you feeling here
I wasn't too happy here like I'm still
up like 30 or 20 seconds on the clock
but
um it's it's difficult to win and uh or
yeah I mean he's just completely fine so
it's very difficult to to win I wasn't
too happy here but uh at some point he
and he he kept spending time
and yeah if we keep going so I thought
like here I'm definitely in favor or I
don't know if I was a favorite to lose
but I mean I still have I still have the
time which always counts for something
so I wasn't too happy here but at some
point okay so A4 I got my Pana but he he
just stops I mean I still have like 20
seconds on the clock which is definitely
something I go King up A3 king of King
E7
um the king of five he takes Bishop C3 I
mean right around here so Bishop D3 E4 I
feel like it cannot be good for me but
as you see I have one minute and 13
seconds he's got 50 seconds and it's not
clear to me how he's gonna promote the
pawn like he can go Bishop B1 and A2 but
my plan my moves are very easy I go King
G6 I take on G7 and at the in the worst
case I can give one of my Bishops
um take all his King side pawns hope for
summing and and of course I always have
the time so
I wasn't necessarily too concerned here
and then of course when he played King
E6 he blundered upon yeah and then I
think it's just over because I'm up uh
20 seconds and it's a king side just
collapses so this is just over yeah this
was a really heartbreaking
he went Bishop A6 because you know yeah
Bishop V6 all of a sudden and then he
found I feel like kind of fun visual
Basics and then King D6 so it's pretty
heartbreaking to see because you know he
just played so hard this whole game and
and he also played such a long game to
qualify to his tie break so it was just
really amazing to see him fight so hard
and as you mentioned the time Advantage
was really big and in your second game
you also chose White against Sam so and
you didn't play anything too theoretical
right you just well this line has some
has some Venom to it and I always see uh
Hikaru play this online so that was kind
of my uh inspiration going into the game
and like you know white keeps the pieces
on the board it's a little bit easier to
play for white and I think like right
around here after Bishop D7 and the good
thing was I think after E3 on the second
move like I got the same thing at least
four for a little bit whereas he's super
booked up and that gave me an edge on
the clock like I think very quickly it
was not a one minute but like one minute
or 30 seconds one minute and 20 seconds
and that that's definitely uh what you
want so I was happy with what I got out
of the opening
um yeah so here yeah it all looks pretty
good I go E4 Rook C8 Rook fe1 perhaps at
some point I just have to go E5 you know
kick the Knight away absolutely and yeah
again like if you look at the clock I'm
up like more than a minute so a minute
and 10 seconds uh but to me it'll look
good to after Queen B6 would take on D5
but yeah yeah so he takes I think all of
this is fine 24 G6 C4 oh this looks good
take take and the one thing though is
that I took a long time for e-takes D5
and again like I'm still up on the clock
yeah like 30 seconds 30 seconds like you
shouldn't like I was talking with a
friend before the game and he told me
like never spend a minute in an
Armageddon game
Advantage right yeah I just found it but
of course so were you considering E5 I
wasn't really considering E5 like I like
the fact that I have my two Bishops on
the on the diagonal so I like this idea
of takes and queen E4 and uh it's kind
of awkward for him to protect and yeah I
saw C4 so he takes Queen d8 yeah all of
this looks really good and then uh when
he played Bishop six I initially missed
it after it takes takes I can't go
Knight D6 because he was 93
but I still like my position like
um after Rook C1
I think I always have
some some pressure but yeah my time
Advantage was dwindling here like here
I'm up like 30 seconds and he he gets a
fine position Baroque fd8 looks pretty
logical Bishop of one I thought was a
good move 97 uh I don't know if 95 was
good but I mean I still have some
pressure but but again like I don't have
as much of an edge on the clock anymore
um and then he got he got his pieces
pretty active so 95 985 Queen E3 so he
took and uh 55 I win 96 so he took Queen
B2
maybe I think like at some point I
should just take the pawn on A6
um and I don't know it's
that's definitely the difference between
like classical and Blitz like in a
classical game you just calculate in the
Blitz game you're like well you know
maybe he will start creating some
threats or I don't know like you want to
keep some sort of control but of course
that's uh that's difficult
so he went uh yeah there nice this just
looks so nice for you because your kid
looks so safe and yeah this Knight on C5
is just beautiful yes another five but
yeah around here time around here was
time was even so that was definitely a
bit concerning
um but okay Queen C3 I thought the end
game should be good for me then Rook D1
I I think I'm still better here like I
have I have the advantage on the board
but of course I'd like to have both like
the advantage on the clock and on on the
board so what happens if you take this
Knight H4 um yeah I'm just I'm just
asking for something to happen like
that's and I thought okay rookie one at
least I pin his Bishop so it's going to
be difficult for him to unleash some
sort of tactic your worksheet and queen
E5 to me looks very pleasant and I
already saw this idea of 97 to F6 but
again like time time is even so pretty
much anything can happen but then he
played A5 quickly I played Knight D7 and
I think here he's just in a world of
trouble like Knight F6 is a major major
threat if he ever goes like King h8 I
take on D5 when or like 94. so already I
I didn't see move from and here he was
thinking for a long time I don't know
how much how long yeah he spent almost a
minute he spent almost a minute and that
pretty much says so yeah after 97 I
think it's just over at least
practically especially after he took so
long did you already at the board did
you feel like you have this in the game
or you were just still coming I mean I
thought like oh this this is looking
really good but of course you can never
you can never relax you should you know
stay focused till the very end um but I
mean Knight F6 is coming like if you
have this in a Blitz game you win this
like 99 of the time
um but he plays there Knight of six take
stakes and yeah here I I pretty much
knew it was over like I'm up
um 30 seconds I have that a pawn running
down the board and I was pretty happy
with how I converted the game I thought
after Bishop B3 G4 was super accurate
like the Knight has to move and here all
of his pieces are loose so that's also
another thing for him like it's very
difficult for him not to drop more
material if he moves tonight than often
Queen B7 and all of his stuff is hanging
and then oh yeah this is just to take
every single piece yeah and Rook C3 or
yeah Rook C3 I can just take the name
never mind okay so yeah Rook C6 and I
just push the pawn and and yeah on top
of that he had no time so I like to hear
how he took the bishop I appreciated
this a lot because this Knight is just
so bad I just take the bishop yeah and
with one minute against 19 seconds and
then you picked up another piece and
those came over yeah this was a very
dominant performance by you and you do
win clear first place picking up six
thousand dollars so there's no type for
you this was a big money round uh so
what is next for you I don't know yet
um it's a good question so yeah I don't
play a whole lot over the board anymore
but this event definitely uh got me you
know fired up again I wanna I wanna play
more but it's kind of it's kind of funny
like like you said I lost the first
round and then the second round I also
played terrible and I'm thinking to
myself like okay what am I why am I
playing this tournament but starting
from round three I I got into it I felt
like I played good chess and I knew
eventually my chances are going to come
and I I took them
um my next tournament I don't know like
over the summer there will be the Dutch
Champion uh Dutch Championship since
I've never won it I definitely want to
win it at least one time you know my
career before I uh retire uh so yeah
that's definitely on uh on my radar for
the rest I
I don't know like oh there's these World
Cup
unfortunately I I didn't qualify like I
didn't play the European championship
and that was my one chance to to qualify
so um hey maybe fetus watching you can't
give me uh can give me a wild card
um but yeah no I I definitely want to
play more uh chess again I want to try
to push for the top 100 try to push for
26.50 I think it's definitely possible
and beyond that of course it's it's not
going to be easy but I I definitely want
to want to play more uh over the board
chess and shift my focus a little bit
more to that you know I feel like cycle
of Jasmine not a professional
flashlight and you're like like you know
what chess is so hard then you have one
good tournament and then you get so
inspired and then you start playing
again and then you play badly and then
you're like no no no no well often often
what happens to people is that they play
a lot and they're like oh this is so
tiring this is stressful and then they
start missing it right and then they
play and they're like oh this is so
difficult and they go back into
retirement
um but yeah I definitely have been
missing it every time like there's a big
event going on like Tada is still chess
I'm kind of like I kind of wish I was
there so now I'm here again and yeah I
think
also for for myself like with every
event I play I feel like there's always
uh something I learned not just from
playing but also the all the the
preparation that's the great thing about
these events because a lot of these
tournaments in the US you play two
rounds a day and you know you you wake
up you prepare some line and you go go
and play and then before you know it
like you're around your game finishes
you have to eat something and you play
again but with these kind of events I
feel like it definitely gives players to
push their game to the next level so
that's why I think it's great for uh
players like Mishra or or Christopher
you who are still very very young to to
play in these or and all the other
prodigies in the in the B group as well
um so I think these events um are great
and yeah maybe I'll I'll play in the
Summer Classic as well yeah I mean I
agree with you because I think there's a
difficult and if you're not playing a
lot what are you doing are you streaming
more you're teaching uh yeah I'm
streaming I'm streaming I'm teaching I
put all my lessons on hold during this
event so you know sorry to my uh to my
students I'll I'll pick up again
um yeah probably from from tomorrow
um and yeah I think I'll do a stream
tonight to to celebrate
um besides that they're they're having
these Olympic Esports Olympic online
Olympic Esports qualifiers which started
today I think there's also
um some tomorrow so I think I'll play in
those uh as well
um so yeah lots of uh lots of Chess um
coming up online tests mostly well uh
best of luck to you
congratulations on winning this event I
hope
I hope for you to play more over the
board and looking forward to seeing you
here more and that was the winner of
group a Benjamin Bach who won two
Armageddon tournaments two Armageddon
games to clinch the title and we do have
the full standings of Group B we did
Crown the champion very early on as
Felix bobberger did finish his game
early but let's take a look at how this
tournament ended so in 10th place we
have Kirk azarian with two and a half
points and in the nine place we have
Balaji dakopati with three and a half
eight plays gergelic Hunter and then
three-way tie between Victor Victor
mikaleski CLEP dude in and Akshay
Chandra and Victor mikhailovski as we
keep saying he's been the most combative
player in this Tournament winning his
game finishing at uh four and a half and
a three-way tie for second place Jason
Leon who was fighting for first place
today unfortunately last year's game and
pamba swimming but Turin joined him with
a draw and so they'd look up with this
foreign
and of course the winner of Group B
Felix bobberger with a tough dominant
performance
he won four thousand dollars going into
this round his performance was 26.92 and
at least probably dropped a bit but
still over 2600 performance and a very
strong finish and in group a we saw this
exhilarating
Armageddon but let's see where everyone
else finished in we had a very tight
tournament as we see the difference
between first place and last place is
only point and a half so we have Daniel
Tartan Abby Mishra who finished with her
and a half Nordic back yakubov at Four
Points and we have illenishnik very
solid performance all draws with four
and a half and Christopher you who was
tied for first place for most of the
tournament
he lost unfortunately lost his game
today and dropped to tie for sixth place
and of course we have this huge tie for
first place between some Savion Benjamin
gadura Tara Swartz Benjamin Park and
Yasser quesada all of whom who scored
five points and of course our big winner
of group a is
um Benjamin buck and as we saw he won
two Armageddon games we did have very
exciting playoff today between five
players we saw Benjamin bug
defeating
Yasser quesada press in the first game
and then in the second game he defeated
some Savion so that was a very exciting
day for us
and many thanks to our crew for all
their help in making this show happen
really appreciate everyone behind the
scenes running the cameras from the
playing coral and
and Michael commentary Julian proleko
Who had who had to leave but thank you
everyone for making this show happen and
thank you everyone for joining us and we
really really appreciate you guys being
here with us and watching this exciting
tournament don't forget our next
tournament is going to be the first stop
of the grand Chester will be the Romania
Superbad classic so please join us on
May 6 on the same channel there will be
live coverage and we look forward to
having you there
thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited